I'm going to start off using haste.
And then I'm going to go ahead and switch to my element, the domain.
And then I'll activate that here.
And then I have one action left.
Swooping in.
Sound in my arms.
What happened?
Let me apply.
I got to make a deck save.
It matches.
He stops and he just stares down at you.
And you forget.
I have these.
He points back to his wings and you don't have wings right now.
All right.
He starts to circle around as both of you start to circle each other.
Maybe we can come to a mutual understanding if you would be willing to listen.
Let's say you.
Well, I feel like being generous today.
After all, you've given me the gift of freedom.
You've let me back in that world again.
And I know better not to meddle with your kind.
What was that being?
That could mean whatever you wanted to mean.
And he's going to just take the sword and he's going to slice at you again.
And he's going to take the sword and he's going to take the sword and he's going to slice at you again.
I like to use a shield.
Pop your shield.
Yeah.
Essentially like gravity kind of like holds the attack.
You go shield.
I'm going to undo the damage.
As the attacker reverberates his hands pulled back.
And he goes.
Oh, someone still has their spiritual left then.
All right.
Come at me.
It's your turn.
This is about to begin.
Does it?
So, do you know what?
They're not most gonna make it as stunning strike.
All right.
Oh, he does fail that.
Ten is going to hit him.
There we go.
And what does he have concentration on?
Oh, the shadow blade.
He does still have the shadow blade as the stunning strike.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, God, David.
What?
How do you how do you stun him?
I don't imagine like a punch that just like makes his ears runes like he's like done.
Okay.
As you swing your hand and right to his like head, his head kind of like disintegrates, sort of
and starts to reconstruct.
And you see like whatever this form of him is is sort of wonderful to your attacks.
And so, this was really one sided.
He would just torture you in your nightmares.
This plane, whatever he is brought you in, seems to be some sort of domain that holds his true self.
As he starts to reconstruct, he looks back at you.
His whole, his both of his hands just limp on his sides.
Looks back at you.
Making that as a no then.
Like you said, we can talk, but I still need to fight.
Do you say he's gonna, yeah, he stunned.
14 does not hit.
Does it.
Okay.
That's just great.
That's three so far right.
That's that's force damage, correct?
Correct.
The other master when I roll it out of man who does.
Plegeny because it doesn't like.
Yeah, that's when that's when this one.
I'll just have to do it manually.
Uh.
In 30 of blows, I can get one more.
Okay, nevermind.
I did it wrong again.
Let me see if I can go in and actually change the damage.
Uh, what was it?
11 does not hit.
22 and 16.
Okay, saves the concentration.
Oh no, he doesn't.
Why?
Uh, key.
That's all right.
All three attacks.
Yeah.
Plus four.
Do you use your haste?
Are you.
Okay.
Your haste is gone now, right?
No.
Why did?
But now it's gone, right?
Was it three turns?
This is my second turn.
Why did my haste go?
I don't know.
Maybe it was from before the fight from before.
It shouldn't have gone.
Anyway, just assume we're still on his.
Okay, so we're still on the ground at the very least.
All right.
He as you just punches body, the parts of his body that were turned into void are kind of blown apart with the force that you're punching it with.
And it's starting to reconstruct.
Once he reconstructs, he disengages and flies up.
But he was done.
He can't move.
Oh, was he stunned for this round as well?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, my sorry, I forgot that it was there around that you stunned him in.
Okay, there we go.
He's still reconstructing himself.
All right, it's your turn now.
I get to have more fun.
Mm-hmm.
One second.
Okay.
Um.
Good.
That's 20.
Okay, max die.
Max die plus max die.
No, no, that was 1d8.
Okay, so that's eight.
Then eight plus three plus eight plus 15.
Eight plus three plus eight.
Okay, go ahead.
What's the next one?
18.
18 does not hit.
I think.
Yes, it's over.
Is this 20 hit?
No, it's over.
It does.
Oh, it's 16.
That was one, two, three, four.
Let's just do another for your blows.
Okay, max die.
Is that it?
Yeah.
You got lucky.
All right.
As soon as you stop, like just punching him over and over,
like dissipating his whole body, he starts reconstructing it
as you still punch, punch, punch.
He still starts to reconstruct it.
And then he goes to him, his whole body has just dissipated
and reformed behind you.
And oh, fucking, fuck me.
What the fuck am I telling you?
And he goes to you.
It seems like your friends out there not having as much as a
good time that you are.
And he's going to show you what's happening behind him.
And I'm going to move to that call.
I should you.
All right.
You all ready?
I'll shoot.
There we go.
As you see him flying up, he gets knocked out by some force
in the air and he just falls back right into the ground.
As this like giant crater farms in his space.
What the fuck?
How do I change this?
Zero.
There we go.
Let me go back to this.
It was his turn.
He is on his knees, but he's not prone.
He did not.
It's just some invisible force just pushing back to the ground.
All right.
It's going to be riffs turn and I'm going to make wisdom safe for him.
Nope. He did not succeed and he's going to run away behind here.
And that's going to be his turn.
Dravos is still just going to hide.
He's not feared, but he's going to hide.
Now that's your turn.
Just start with making wisdom safe.
Oh my god.
13, yep.
He is not going to.
I'm just saying.
T-Gore.
Come on.
Roma can.
Roma is still there.
I'm out here.
He's a bar.
We had the best wisdom.
Roma.
No.
Oh wait.
I wrote it in private.
I'm going to run over here.
I'm going to help this fucking dude.
What are you going to say to Malthus to mix, snap him out of this predicament that he's in?
I'm going to run over there.
I'm literally just going to put my hand on his shoulders and be like, mother fuck it, this is supposed to be our get back.
And then like light smack him.
And then like that.
I don't know.
The pressure that you're feeling.
It is your turn.
Go to your token selection and then move.
I think you're not using the.
Okay, that's your action.
Do you want to do something as a bonus?
Oh 100%.
Actually.
I'm going to do this.
Fuck this.
I just told him it's time for our get back.
All right, go ahead, transform.
Let's fucking.
So then my walk is still.
Wait, sorry.
So it's five into four.
That's 20.
There you go.
No, no, the 10 page feed.
The 10 page fee was incorrectly.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
So the.
Yeah, 35.
That's fine.
Yep.
All right, it's his turn.
He looks down and he just mumbled something to himself.
Can.
Tee-Gor.
Can you make a perception?
I think Roma is also nearby.
You can also make a perception.
I think it'll help.
You're still exhausted.
Yeah, I'm.
Yeah, he's wrong.
Okay, yeah.
Kane, sorry, Tee-Gor.
You do here under his breath.
He just curses out Baptiste.
And that's it.
And as he stands up, he goes.
If it's like that, then witness this.
He just points a finger at.
Roma.
It's.
Can you make a con save?
I don't know if you fail.
It's a pretty high con.
I'm not going to lie.
You're a barbarian fighter.
Come on.
Oh, okay.
Save.
Why?
You're a barbarian fighter.
Come on.
Save.
Why are you rolling with disadvantage?
Because I have my exhausted.
No, it's only checks.
Only checks.
Oh, go check.
Yeah, just roll normally.
There you go.
I still.
All right.
He.
He just points at you, Roma.
He just like black void.
He just essentially hits you right in your chest.
And that's going to do.
Let's see if you can even.
There we go.
That's 52.
That's 20.
That's 17.
So 52 will just.
Okay.
52 minus 17 minus 20.
That's 15.
So you take 15 damage after you're knocked out.
So you are knocked out.
You're not dead.
Right off dead.
But you do go out of your hybrid form as soon as you transform.
That's what you see, Baptiste.
Okay.
That's going to be his turn.
It's riffs turn.
Let me see if he can save and maybe try to help Roma.
Does Barrett work on.
Saving throws.
No, right.
It's only ability to check.
I can't roll does.
Roma didn't even know who Barrett gets variation still.
Yeah.
If he rolled max, it wouldn't matter.
No, no.
It's where we're still be 17, which is not enough.
Never mind.
All right, just save it for when you're back.
I don't know if it stays if you're fucking unconscious.
Okay.
Let me make a wisdom save for.
Come on.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's this turn.
Let me read it once again fear.
The only thing about me is that we're supposed to be out of sight.
We're always the same.
And we're supposed to be running away.
Yeah.
Well, they.
You can't really run when you're trapped in a place.
Yeah.
Oh, I can't believe this is the end of the story.
I'm not going away from you by the safest available route on each of turn.
Unless there's nowhere to move.
If the creature ends his turn in location where it doesn't have the line inside of you,
the creature must make.
Yeah, I don't think it has a line of sight against him.
He's behind the pillar.
Yeah, I can just go to the next island.
I helped you, dog.
Remember?
Yeah, he's up.
He's up.
Well, I rolled with advantage, that's.
Yeah.
Drave is going to look at what just happened.
And I'm going to have to make a wisdom save at this point.
Yeah, he's not going to run away.
Unfortunately, he's going to go to.
He's going to go out.
Oh, shit.
I knew I liked him.
I don't know if he's all I'll be back.
I don't get.
Hey, I'm knocked out.
I can't say shit.
Okay, wall of pipes is essentially.
Let me read this.
After I told you.
To like, hey, man, this is supposed to be our get back.
I slapped you and ran and literally just got obliterated.
No.
Okay, he's going to create like a big wall of pipes around this guy.
Just just a huge area is just wall of just pipes inside this pipe.
He's just trapped in completely.
It's going to be drabos this turn.
It's you, Malthus.
There's only an opening from above.
You can't see him.
Make a wisdom save with advantage.
It's just not meant to be.
T-Gore make a save with advantage this time.
The roles today are not in our favor.
Okay, T-Gore is out.
I'm going to make a save with the riff.
What are you doing, T-Gore?
Well, you said there's no way to attack him besides.
Nope.
Riff also saves, by the way, 18.
He's just going to dash and move towards Roma and get him up.
Let me do a medicine check.
I just got a prep for when he does.
He has stabilized Roma and he is going to as a bonus.
Give him a med kit.
Where's the inventory?
I'm going to have a period clause.
Then he doesn't have to show rooms.
I can't be bad.
Give me a day.
It's hard to be able to do this.
Roma, you get saving HP back.
You can still use your hybrid one more time.
All right.
I think I'll really just fill again.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Why did I do riff?
Riff was not in turn.
Anyway, he's going to do that all of that next turn.
Roma, can you also make a dead save just in case?
At worst, you're going to roll a critical and that's two.
So that doesn't really matter.
Why are you clicking initiative?
I'm not.
Every time I pull up my character sheet.
Oh, I see.
I don't know.
Maybe it's bugbed out.
All right.
So you just, while shape is an action, right?
Do you have any bonus or?
I did the bonus vampire clause.
Oh, I see.
I know.
I'm just going to act like a silver.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
Roma Stern happened.
It's this guy's turn.
He's going to just fly straight up.
Trying to get out of.
It's fine, it's fine.
He's going to get you up anywhere next turn.
Let's find.
Let's take the skeleton below your head.
Do do do do do do do do do do.
Let me see.
He just fly straight up 40 feet.
He's still not able to get out of the pipe.
The pipe is very big.
It's a let me check.
How was the range?
All of pipe is 1 1/2 inch thick.
10 by 10 foot panels, 10 feet radius.
How long is it?
That's what I want to know.
I guess it's just 10 feet.
He's just going to fly straight up.
No, 100 feet wall.
Okay, never mind.
100 feet.
It's 100 feet.
So he's just going to use his complete dash to get to 80 feet up straight up.
He's still not out of the wall yet.
So he can't see you still.
Riff is going to do all of that.
Roma, you're up.
Draveau's is going to go to.
K and he goes.
He's trapped.
No, listen.
Let's make a one for me.
What are you doing?
What are you asking me to ask on for?
I'm just going to say that guy's inside.
Captain still.
What about Captain?
It's as if I were going to go get some reinforcements.
How about this?
We are not able to fight that thing.
Prepare.
You're just a person.
As far as I can tell.
But I'm a part of this crew.
I'm going to go and find some reinforcements.
He just heads down the stairs.
Use this as dash and run away.
Now if this can you please please get the fuck out.
You have you have plus three with the man.
What the fuck?
Oh, I guess.
Fucking finally.
Okay, mouth as you snap out of it.
This hatred toward that thing keeps growing inside of you.
Every turn you feel pushed down by losing another one of your kind.
Now this burning just pure rage is within you.
What are you doing?
I'm going to go get the fuck out of you.
That was in the action.
All the saves are not actions yet.
You have to go around.
I mean, you can fly, but just tell me where you want to go.
I'll just drag you there.
The wall is around here.
Let's say this 10 feet.
That's the wall.
You just surround it by it like this.
Where do you want to go?
Just point at it.
I'll move you.
Just going to go up.
I try to open the fence.
It closes the gate.
Just right click.
Right click on your token.
And then you can input.
Yes, no, but I can't.
I can't flash it for a second.
I can't close it again.
How many feet?
30 feet up or 60?
60 just straight up.
No, wait.
Just put 40.
40.
You only use your action.
You cannot use that.
That's fine.
Okay, T-Gore is your turn.
I'm not my action.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead.
Fireball to where?
The wall is going to block anything.
Did he say he wasn't bothered?
No, it's 100 feet tall.
What do you want to do?
You can still dash.
If you have an action, you can still dash.
Yeah, dash.
That's another 60.
That's 100 so you can fly straight up.
Just 100.
No, that's going to be 60 feet up or 60 feet ladder.
You can't do both.
Right?
You can move diagonally, but it's not going to be then 60 feet.
The distance.
It's going to be, let me quickly can't wait.
25 and then 60 up.
Somewhere in between.
You're going to be somewhere around 50, 80 feet around him.
I guess you're both flying straight up to the same point.
Let me move you around.
It's annoying.
The Foundry is annoying.
There we go.
You're around 80 as well.
All right, a T-Gore.
Well, T-Gore can't do anything right now.
Nothing in his items.
He's not here.
You still have a med kit.
Wow.
We can't see him right now, right?
No.
Just like this whole thing.
Let me just put down.
Uh, uh, uh.
Uh.
This, this, this, this, and this.
He's essentially just surrounded by walls like this.
I'll go over to Roma.
He's a med kit.
I'm tired of getting Roma.
I'll tell you.
Oh, thank you, big daddy.
There we go.
You're at 15 Roma.
Nothing told me to find where I'd be useful.
Was that useful?
Roma.
He's talking to you.
I was 100% useful.
Why don't, what did I say you, you useful?
Captain said be useful.
Yeah.
You have to make out.
All right, Roma, it's your turn.
The only thing I can do is transform.
Go ahead.
I don't know what's happening.
Just just, uh, it's fine.
Just leave it.
I think you were somewhere at the end anyway.
So it's fine.
It's not gonna change anything.
Yeah, it wasn't good.
Yeah.
If it changes, it changes.
You know, we'll just consider it's.
It's what the fate wants.
Transform again.
Yep.
All right, go ahead.
Uh, no, 15 plus 20, 20 temp.
You, you, you share the same health pool now, unlike before, before it was wild shape.
Now it's the same.
It was temporary health you get.
Yeah, yeah.
You do get 20 temporary HP.
That's your bonus.
Uh, what else do you want to do?
Right now between you, you can see mouth is just flying straight up.
These two guys are around you trying to get you up.
As you transform, the cold starts to spread as both of them kind of back off.
What are you doing?
That, um, actually, did I?
What the fuck is ice armor?
Armor of Agatis.
No one.
I probably renamed it.
Yeah, yeah, I want to buff our.
Just click armor, uh, Agatis in spells.
That's a bonus action.
You, you can do that.
You already use your bonus.
Yep.
You can use jump is also a bonus action.
I mean, uh, dark pole, they're in blast.
You can.
Yeti spring.
You can use Yeti spring.
But that's just 10 feet.
Yeah, just jump or cast bring one of the two.
Yeah, I can do anything.
I transform and literally say, hey, thanks guys.
I mean, you can still climb up the thing.
You do, you do have, you do have climb.
If you fall, I'm just gonna wait.
I'm gonna transform and be like, I'm away from these motherfuckers come down.
You can just say something to Baptiste.
Malthus then.
Oh my god, I'm dashing giving out these level ups.
Left and right.
Yeah.
Hey, get your get back.
I try to get fucked up.
It's your turn for the fucker.
All right.
Now at this point, I'm gonna switch back to Baptiste flight.
The inner demons.
Let me bring you up and there you go.
And who's turned was it?
It's his turn.
Okay, as he shows you, him pointing at Roma behind you, just blowing through his chest,
that is all you see.
And he's gonna go each and every one of you is going to die by my hands.
You will survive, you will witness the horrors that are brewing upon them and their loved ones.
I have seen what you want.
Are you Tokyo for your kind?
Don't make me laugh.
Your kind is gone.
Other you believe it or not.
And he's gonna...
I'll do it.
It's 15.
It does not hit, right?
No.
Okay.
And he's gonna do...
Bonus action shadow blade.
As he points another finger at you, as the blast just goes straight through you because
of your elemental body, the void starts to form shape again in his hands in the form
of a blade.
Alright, it's your turn.
You know nothing of my people.
You who have been alone all this time.
You who want to take the body of someone, of the people you know nothing about.
If I know one thing, it's I'm not letting you get out of this place on scale.
Let's get to work.
That's not what I...
That's not what I need.
Oh no.
No.
We should end it really through you.
I've seen fucking Roma die.
That does not get either.
Is that all?
Yeah, that's all.
Okay, go ahead, go ahead.
The emotion is getting to that teeth in the clouding his judgment right now.
Everywhere he said, it's just not probably the right moment.
As you're throwing these fists at him, he uses the void arms to just grab your fists,
throw them away, throw them away, throw them away, throw them away.
And he starts pushing you backwards.
And he goes, is that all that teethed?
Is that all you have?
Where did that passion of yours go?
I have met people like you before.
People who think they will exceed their own mortality.
You can try to conquer whatever you want, but you will never outlive me.
You will never outlive your death.
And he's going to just cast a fireball right at you.
Is he not right next to...
Yeah, he's going to point it somewhere here so it doesn't explode right in his face.
As you see, the fire behind him mimics yours, but it's of a different shape.
It's like sparkly, all purple, as these green flames also emit through it,
like sparkles, little sparkles.
He just snaps his fingers as this small fireball goes straight behind you
and just loops around and hits you in the back.
Can you make a...
Oh my god.
Can you make a dex-sefe?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
That succeeds.
So you take half of this.
15 and 15's half is...
Seven.
No, no.
That's how it's done.
So that's seven.
Let me just do that manually.
No, no.
As these flames engulf you, you feel this weight that you've been carrying all your life,
the weight that you know that there must be a way,
there must be a way for your kind to survive in this world,
for your kind to get back to what they once were,
the top of the red line, the people that were called the heralds of God.
It's your turn.
At least I'm going to take a deep breath at the start of this turn.
Just elect himself.
And behind you, you see riff running towards Roma.
You see even T-Gore running towards Roma and trying to get him up.
He's the slight movement in Roma's fingers as he starts to move.
You don't get up.
So why should I?
Deep breath.
Let's do this.
Wait, I can't.
Yeah, I'm not doing that in the break back.
Okay.
Deep breath.
It in.
Swing again.
That hurts.
That's for my crew.
That's a break.
Oh my god, he fails.
And the damage for first one.
There you go.
18 does not hit.
Yeah, 18 does not hit.
12 does not hit.
18 does not hit.
That's the turn.
As a turn, you don't have any.
I just used my last spare points.
As another one of your punches just knocks straight into him.
As his head again tears a bar and starts to reform.
You want to say something to him.
I'm not going to say anything.
It seems to be saying something but you can't really tell what it is.
I think my words actually means a thing.
Mrs.
Okay, that hits.
Okay, how do you want to end this?
I want to end it with throwing one more punch but I will say something.
I just want to have the last punch to see if I land it.
Okay.
What the second punch?
Oh my god.
That's where my people, the one deep doubt it.
Because we will rise again.
I'll make sure that.
And then the last punch.
And this one.
This one's for the world that you want to take.
But I'm here to tell you once more.
You're not getting this world.
And then just avoid arms.
All just search.
The first two that missed.
They grabbed him where he can't resist.
That's why they didn't do it.
And then the last two punch him.
So split him up.
Okay.
As you punch through the last one, as you grab both of the arms, grab two of his hands.
And the last punch essentially just pairs him up in two pieces.
His face at this point is fully formed.
And as he's disappearing in mid air.
Like burned flakes.
He's disintegrating piece by piece.
I think this is the end.
I will be back, Papthiste.
And this time, I will not spare a single one of those miscarings.
I will be back.
Be prepared.
You think you have control?
We'll see for how long.
As his face at this point just disappears.
I'm going to move back to the main fight now.
Come back.
Oh, see.
Come on.
Come back.
Let me come back here.
Who's turned was it?
It was his turn.
He is going to keep flying straight up.
Let me go back to the map.
Straight up to about 110 feet.
As soon as he's out, he's probably going to see you.
So I'm just going to keep it there.
And he's going to save his action to do whatever.
There we go.
It will trigger as soon as he sees something, someone at the top.
No, Tiko, why is he at the top?
It's Riff's turn.
Riff goes as all of you are waiting there.
Shouldn't we help him?
Anyway, what the fuck is even happening at this point?
He's going to go enhance the exterior to
to Malfus.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God, I'm going to lose it.
I'm going to enhance the ability and the handstick's sturdy.
Oh, my God.
The handstick's sturdy.
There you go.
It's going to be his turn.
Dravo is still running away.
It's your turn, Malfus.
You see you're going to go up.
Well, I can't do much from here.
Yeah, as soon as you're out, you see him at the same time.
And he's going to do something.
What are you going to do?
All right.
He's going to hit him and he's also going to hit you.
17.
Okay.
He's going to hit you again.
If he saves his action, he already has one action.
No, he's using what he call it.
He's still has haston.
Yeah, there's one more attack only.
He's the only one more attack.
He has an on-master.
He can do bonus attacks.
Well, not as a fucking prepared action.
Oh, you me as a prepared action.
I mean, it's just for free-waring.
I didn't want to go up, beat your ass down.
I wanted to make it different.
Anyway, none of those had any way.
So it doesn't matter.
He comes up, he sees you, he's kind of surprised as he just throws this flurry blows as you dodge
each and every one.
What are you doing?
With a room I shot him from last time.
He had a health action.
If he didn't do anything.
I mean, you already have enhanced decks.
So, I mean, it's up to you.
But the difference would be really good eventually.
No, I'm going to say no, you don't get that.
Okay, you have free-worthy blows.
What are you complaining about?
Yeah, it does it.
How is 27 not a crit?
I don't understand.
What was it in 19?
Oh my god.
All right, go ahead.
Okay, you make me a con safe, please.
Okay, stunning strike.
I see what you're going to.
Hmm, see.
Oh god, okay.
He's got a burn his legendary resistance on this.
Thank you.
You see your hands land on it on his head right around the area.
As soon as your hand lands on it, he turns it into void as your hands just pass through.
But it does damage him somewhat.
It doesn't hit.
Another.
What is the enhanced fucking decks even doing?
Is he?
It says you have advantage on ability, dexterity ability checks.
Why aren't you doing it with advantage?
Not a lot of decks.
It's a not a build to checks.
No, dexterity ability.
Oh, ability check.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, go ahead.
I was thinking something else.
I thought it would give you like points or something in decks.
I don't know.
16.
Doesn't it have the fucking barric than her?
Doesn't it?
Well, does me.
Was that with flurry of blows?
Yeah, I wrote first time.
Okay.
I need to be on one ten as well.
Yeah, yeah, let me do that.
All right, that's him.
T-Gore is your turn.
Go T-Gore.
Aren't they a hundred feet in the air?
A hundred and ten to be exact.
Yes.
At this point, T-Gore just sees clouds and just the wall.
This PVC pipe wall.
That's it.
Oh, you'll seek clouds for the seconds.
[laughs]
Wait, what's the range on this?
What thing?
120 feet.
Nice.
Eve a lie.
All right, go ahead.
Cast it.
What's the safe?
It's a can trip.
Oh, what's the safe for me?
I don't say it.
Oh, I have a nice memory.
It says you wear a creature within range and pose a note below.
Well, hex on it.
The target takes one before it goes to second range.
Attack rolls and unarmed strikes against it can score a critical hit on a roll of 19 or 20.
So roll that 20.
Okay.
Before me.
I rolled the 19.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay.
Okay, that's one damage to him.
Great.
Good job, guys.
Fuck you.
All right, it's your turn.
[inaudible]
Yeah, I'm just trying to figure out.
You can still throw the lands.
I think you still have a couple of Javilins left.
I don't know how many.
Yeah, but I don't know.
I had to get 120 feet.
It is, I think 120 feet.
It is literally 30 to 120 feet.
Yeah.
So like I would have to max this roll out.
Yeah, yeah.
So I have bardic inspiration.
So fuck it.
Let's do it.
Yeah, go ahead.
I'm going to say, because we're not,
we haven't counted how many Javilins you've thrown.
I'm going to say you have thrown all of them at this point.
So then I can't.
Okay.
No, no, just throw it.
This is the last one that you have on you.
That's what I'm saying.
I think.
[Sighs]
What do we do side push?
Side push.
It's only equal to your devil fruit usage.
That's it.
15 does not hit.
Uh, uh, uh.
Uh, he's going to look at you, Malfas,
and he's going to just grab you.
Can you make a contested strength?
No, if it's grapples, I can move fucking a desk.
Uh, uh, uh, is it contested strength or is it?
Let me check grappling.
Grapple, if you have to do strength, I can choose.
I have to do strength, right?
There you go.
I don't know normal, because I am next to everyone.
No, you don't have to roll normal, why would you roll normal?
Oh, oh, yes, yes, yes.
Uh, you succeed, and he's going to try to.
At this point, he tries to grab you one with one of the actual arms that Baptiste has.
He tries to grab you, and as soon as you like dodge out of the way, he's going to throw a punch.
There we go, attack.
16.
This is 11.
Sorry, now 15.
Oh, my God.
19.
That hits one more.
Okay.
The first one will do.
We'll also do minus three, that means because of the time thing, right?
The three HP.
Yeah, yeah, 18.
And it's going to be another 18.
Okay, yeah, 18.
This is total of 33.
0.
No, yeah, 33, 56.
Oh, 23.
All right, as he just drills down two of those astral fists right in your face, can you?
I'm going to say you're on top of the wall, so you don't fall down.
So you're just on there, both of you in the 10 feet area.
All right, that's going to be a stern.
Riff is going to look up top and he shouts out.
This goes.
And that's it.
Oh, God, I was the wrong person.
Sorry, sorry.
I know it is annoying the A.E. Let me remove the bardic inspiration on him.
Let me target you.
And let me do it again.
Doesn't bother going to have a rage of 60.
Does it?
It does.
No, mine.
Okay, now I did it for both of you.
Nice.
Okay.
Malphus.
What are you doing?
Draveus is gone.
He's not in the fight anymore.
Malphus is here.
As he's punching you, he also goes.
You think you're strong enough to save him?
He doesn't need you.
No one ever needed you.
Stay the fuck down and get out of my way.
What's this?
24 hits.
Make another concierge.
Okay.
Let me see.
Why do I still have it on private?
God damn it.
10.
Fails.
So you're fucked out.
Yes.
And that's 11 d6.
Can I roll?
No, no.
He's on, like I said, you're on the roof, I think.
That's what I said last time.
He's not going to fall down.
You want to push him?
You can push him.
It's fine.
Let me do.
Instead of my second attack, I just push him.
Okay, go ahead.
Drop down, please.
One, two, can I roll?
Yeah, yeah, roll.
Okay, let's start 11 p fixed.
39.
120 feet, right?
No, it's 110.
Okay.
Okay, he starts to fall and he hits the ground.
You see his body completely transformed into lazy, like,
splat on the ground and he's trying to reform his shape.
What are you doing?
Okay.
Let me do, save.
Am I still in private?
What is happening?
Okay, now I'm good, maybe.
Let's see.
Just click transform.
Hopefully it works.
Yes.
Okay, there we go.
What?
It did work.
What happened?
The actual thing she added, like this, feet and the.
Is it gone?
It's safe.
Oh, I see.
Just, just.
Just assume you have that.
Yeah.
And just next time in the transformation thing, you have the access.
You can just change it.
Because I forget.
Oh, I don't have access to the second form.
Okay.
I'll change it.
I'm changing.
Okay, so you transform as you punch him right in, like, his throat.
He, like, chokes up and you just, like, essentially just push him down, like,
just stab him and he just starts falling and you see, like, a big black splat around the floor.
And he's trying to gather up and just in the next turn, he's just going to use all his movement to just fly up with the haste.
That's plus 100.
I'm floating down 70 again.
Okay.
And around this point, the wall would start to collapse as Drago's is basically out of the range.
So let me remove this.
Okay, there we go.
As you're falling straight in and the wall has lifted.
So everyone now can see what's happening.
T-Gore, what are you doing?
He's on the floor.
He can.
Yes.
Hit him.
So he's probably...
He is prone.
Yeah.
You're trying to reconstruct his body.
Usually that's how it happens.
[Laughter]
You're not using the correct ones.
Oh, yeah, never mind.
And that's what I was wrong with.
[Laughter]
There was something now.
We're almost trying to mold people, even if it's a bad taste.
Okay.
It does not hit.
T-Gore, as you're trying to slash through the void, it's just forming around your hits as the last one does land.
[Laughter]
All right.
That gives you my...
[Laughter]
Ten pages.
Just add your 10 page fee.
Yeah.
I'm doing it manually.
Rommas, your turn.
What are you doing?
[Laughter]
All right.
Come on.
Why is it okay?
Let's do it this way.
All right.
Let me apply that on you.
There we go.
You're raging now.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
So I'm going to move there, and then here.
Sorry.
What the...
Yeah, let me...
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is happening?
Okay, there we go.
There.
There we go.
Like, hold up.
So...
I'm there.
You know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Just going to bump.
Twenty hits.
Oh.
Woo-hoo.
So that's the first one.
Nine damage.
Do I want to eat?
Yes.
You know what?
For my second attack, I'm going to do this.
What the hell?
Ice Knight.
All right.
Go ahead.
Like, you won't let me rip you, Gord.
Just click on Ice Knight and remove consume spell slot.
I think you don't have any...
You use all of your users, I think, for the devil fruit.
So you can't use it.
Oh, the spirit.
I'll just switch again with the pan.
All right.
Go ahead.
I think the pan was a replacement for a great sword.
It should be 1D12.
I don't know.
We'll just change it.
We'll just change it for future.
Oh, because I think we made it a Warhammer.
A great, more great club.
Because of blushing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I think it was a great club or something.
I think it was a great club.
passed you and he's just standing there, seething.
Assistant, Riff is going to come in and if he is,
going to go combat inspiration.
Wait, what the fuck is he saying?
Combat inspiration, what do you want?
Damage defense, Roma.
So I want to do more damage.
Yeah, I'm going more damage, bro.
All right, go ahead.
Also, third level, you learn to inspire this in matter of
a creature that has body conspiracy die from you can
roll, then die and add the number of roll to a weapon damage
roll is just made.
Okay.
Okay, you can use this damage anytime.
So that's I think 1d6.
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
For the next time, whenever you attack him,
drabos is gone.
Alpha's.
Yeah, let's start curbs top of this.
Yeah, I was going to do something funny, but that might be better.
You all have you all have advantage.
Yep.
You can do colliding.
I don't think it's going to hit anyone else.
Or is it like 10 feet?
Yeah, I would have hit all of you.
Yeah.
I'm not the best position, but I guess it is what it is.
It would be funny.
It would be like, fuck everyone.
I'm burning all bridges.
I go ahead and advantage.
24 hits.
How about you know, everyone has their turn.
Just just fucking roll.
Yeah, let me do mine first.
Let's do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go ahead.
So the first one hits.
And minus lightning damage.
So I guess it also goes past his resistance.
Yes.
But he is going to have a tribute that for sure.
That's fine.
Can you make a deck safe?
I can.
When you want to succeed, okay, but you do take half of this.
Half and half again, because I...
Fire resistance, yes.
So that's 11, 11 divided by two.
That's five.
So you take five damage as this flame,
like beam of energy just hits off of you.
That was still my temp HP, so that's fine.
There we go.
I have three more attacks to give.
All right, go ahead.
What was the first one?
13.
Yeah.
21, no, you haven't rolled yet.
Why do you throw it to myself?
Actually, can everyone...
I'm just seeing if everyone will hit this turn or no.
So the second one does hit.
That may...
Just roll, just roll.
Everyone just rolled, because regardless, I think he's going to go down.
Can...
You can use your bardic.
It's not going to help anyway.
19, 11, 14 does not hit.
20 does hit, and that's another 11.
And...
Yeah, T-Gore is not hitting.
Roma, do you want to do your frenzy or anything?
Or extra attack?
Yeah, my extra attack was a 23.
Yeah, that does hit.
That's missed.
All right, I don't think it's enough still.
There's that plus my electro.
That's...
Straight damage.
So right now I have...
Who's that?
11?
Nope, that's mouth as fuck.
I did...
Seven...
Eight, nine, ten, eleven.
I did 11 right now.
Okay, mouth as well.
We use total.
There's total damage.
No, always total damage.
11 and...
Another 11, that's 22 plus 21.
So at 43.
43 is still not enough.
He is...
I'm going to pop the frenzy then.
All right, go ahead.
We're going to do it.
All right.
Does not hit.
I'm going to pop the particles for each to add the six.
Just roll 1d6.
Okay.
What does it mean?
It's for you or more.
Yeah, I think it has to be three or one.
Nope, that does not hit.
Roma, you can add your 1d6 to the damage you dealt earlier,
but that still won't be enough.
So...
Yeah, it's still not...
It's still not going to be enough.
As you just start beating into him,
everyone just fucking punching.
You're slamming your skillet into his face
and...
Tigo, you're just struggling because you don't know how to hit this guy.
He just keeps...
He just keeps getting...
getting away with every attack just passing through.
And he, at the end of his turn,
will go...
and he's just going to...
Earthquake.
Yes.
Fabteens, fucking him up on the inside, like the mine part?
Hey, you know, you know.
Like...
Fuck, dude.
What is this?
Oh, I gotta...
Be good, spy.
Hi!
So...
I failed.
Yeah, I hit a belt.
Uh...
Okay, let me see.
(singing)
For the duration intense tremor rips through the ground,
100 foot radius centered at the point shakes every creature,
structure and contact.
The ground in the area becomes difficult terrain,
each creature on the ground, concerning...
Okay, and a fail save, the creature concentration becomes broken.
I don't think any of you are concentrating on anything.
As you spell.
At the end of his turn,
you spend concentrating on any creature on the ground,
mistake of dexterity saving throw,
and a fail save of the creature is not prone.
Spell can have additional effects terrain.
Uh...
Spell area...
Your next turn.
Okay, cool.
Uh...
Does gonna be the end of his turn.
As...
It's riffs turn...
And he is going to...
At the start of everyone's turn,
I think they have to make a deck save as well, right?
To not get knocked prone.
Or is it only on movement?
Let me check.
(singing)
Where is it?
That's quick.
I'm having a...
Uh...
I think it has the end of each turn.
You spend concentrating on any creature on the ground,
must make a dexterity saving throw.
Oh, everyone has to make a deck saving throw, right now.
Oh, no. You already did, right?
I don't know what I'm doing.
(laughing)
Is feature on the ground that is concentrating,
must make a concentration, that's fine.
Structures.
They travel these 50 bludgeoning damage to any structure.
Take them with the ground.
Structure drops to 0 HP.
And the creature...
It collapses, but it's damaging to my creature.
Oh, that's fine.
You just outrooted.
No, no, no, no.
I was just reading.
I'm just making sure...
I'm reading correctly.
But prone is nothing.
Brown is you get up, you fucking punch him again.
(laughing)
I'm throwing at this point.
Yeah.
I'm gonna be the raw food.
Uh...
All right, so he's gonna do...
Is it short-rest?
I assume music will advertise your view
during a short-rest, no mind.
Uh...
He's gonna heat metal...
Your...
Uh...
Skillet Roma.
He's gonna what?
Sorry.
Heat metal, your skillet.
He's a heat metal?
Yeah, you can add 2D-8 fired amiss to it from now.
All right.
That's his turn.
Yeah.
Uh...
He's gonna go...
Oh, Thunderbird.
It's your turn.
Hold on.
Or a fact,
when about this?
Go ahead.
Can you also make a perception for me?
He didn't?
He didn't miss his...
He didn't miss his, yes.
Puch-chuch-chuch.
Roll the damage.
Max damage?
Max damage.
Uh...
All right.
Make the other two.
That's it.
Roll the damage.
And the last one.
No, no, no.
I'm just waiting because it takes so long.
Yeah, because I...
I can't find really.
That's a die.
Best damage advantage.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
It's fucking foundry, man.
I could have just said, like, roll fucking...
Three times with...
I made a death.
All right.
Baptiste, you are back.
And you see three...
Back to back punches, land on your face.
Let me remove you.
Let me put Baptiste back here.
(singing)
That's why I made him do the perception check.
So you could figure out if you were back or not.
But every single one of these punches
would like the electric...
Try...
Like...
Electrifies you as you're shocked and just collapse on the ground.
And you guys can see the wings going away.
And the blue... like, purple...
Crystals formed on Baptiste's body
and the black grew all over his face.
Just disappears right into those rings again.
As he collapses back on the ground.
Baptiste, you are unconscious.
There we go.
Wait.
All right.
The building is now collapsing.
Oh, fuck.
Yes.
The whole building is falling.
So...
Who's...
Where is Dravel's?
You need...
Rescuing...
Who?
I don't know if Dravel's made it out of there.
Oh, I hear.
Robo, who got you, Gary?
Not a damn person.
I'm exhausted by two levels, bro.
Like, I'm gonna be struggling to get my ass out of there.
Uh...
Okay.
What's the plan, guys?
Riff at this point is going to...
You take him.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try to get out of there myself.
Roma, can you...
Just punch all the rocks that are falling on all these floors
while we make our way down?
I know the shares probably not the right way to leave,
but it's our only option.
You take Baptiste back to the ship.
We're gonna make it out.
I'll pick up Baptiste and float them down.
I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
I'm round and you said stairs.
How about you just like...
I hate to say this, but I've laid sideways
and you just rolled my ass down the stairs.
[laughs]
You know what?
It's something.
We can try that.
Uh...
He...
Riff gets on top of your shoulders like behind you.
And...
Uh...
T-Gore also gets behind you.
And near the stairway where the like circular stair was,
they will start like just pushing you.
And as soon as they push on you,
they're just going to start balancing on you
as you're rolling down on words.
Uh...
So...
T-Gore, can you make a deck save for me?
Oh my god.
It almost did.
Uh...
Riff has a 21, so he's gonna try...
to grapple you.
You're gonna log, Riff?
Yeah.
Okay, I think that...
I think that should be enough.
As T-Gore is falling off,
he couldn't balance himself.
Riff just catches him and gets him on the ball again.
As all of you make your way down
to the base of this building.
And you see like the whole building just slowly
and just ripping apart,
like parts of it falling on to like nearby buildings.
As the complete building now just leans toward the opera house
and just completely collapses on itself.
And you guys are safe.
Malthus, where did you take Baptist?
Well, I probably just flew down at the side of the building.
The building will be like falling apart.
You wanna make some deck saves then?
Well, I mean, I would like go down at the base.
No, it will.
Well, Robo is falling on the...
Okay, but you said like you're right around
or do you wanna just fly up
as the building collapses
and then you put him down?
I mean, yeah, that also works.
Yeah, okay.
You take Baptist up, you see his wounds just becoming worse
and worse as you're flying up.
He's bleeding very much.
And what is your decision?
Do you wanna take him down?
Or do you wanna take him to the ship?
I'm gonna take a good ship.
Okay.
Can you give...
So what is where it's lost bark?
Yeah, yeah, they said that it's exactly at the same place.
So can you give me...
(humming)
Conceive, one conceive.
Just to see if you are not exhausted too much.
Oh, no.
Well, guess we both died about this.
Yep.
Oh my god, why do you always fail?
It comes to this shit.
Oh god.
Okay, that's saving through Jesus Christ.
What are you doing?
I didn't ask you to make that save through all of it.
You feel heavy as you start to fall downwards
and you land on top of a building.
That's it.
That's all we know about you.
And now we're gonna move...
We're gonna move to Roma, Riff and Tigor.
You...
Can everyone make a perception to see if you all saw them fall
or you just saw them flying toward the ship or not?
(sighs)
Oh, gold!
You saw that, bro.
Yeah.
Let me check for Riff.
Roma, that he did that.
Yeah.
Roma won the edit.
Well, Roma, this is shit.
Riff, Riff did see it.
Riff sees it.
He taps you.
Roma, he just points you at mouth is just straight falling
on a building.
It's up to you.
Riff goes, "Okay, I need to get to my people."
You got it covered, right?
I think Malfa's having some trouble over there.
How about this?
I'm gonna meet you back at your ship once I get everything settled here.
And, well, the tower is gone, so I'm assuming that the jaw locks are open.
But, worse comes to worst.
We'll have to figure out some other way to open them.
All right.
See you guys again.
He's gonna just run off back to the tunnel that he got you up in.
He's gonna run off there.
We're gonna have to go get Malfa's T-Gur.
I'm sorry to say this, but it may take us a while.
I'm fucking tired.
Okay. Roma, can you also make a con save?
Con save.
So no disadvantage.
Just straight con save.
Woo!
Okay. Roma, you feel your knees just giving up at this point,
but you are going to get yourself back up and you are going to see this through.
Where are you going?
Okay.
You, as you walk through the city, you see these houses that are nowhere near this place in the noble district.
This is done by something huge, a monstrous thing that you cannot even comprehend.
And you're walking past it.
T-Gur, you also see this.
By the way, Roma, because of your whistle, you see two of the horses that when away are running towards you now.
Can I see if there are people on them?
No, no, there's just the horses that you tied up back at the entrance.
Perfect.
A-T-Gur, I'm going to have to take both these horses.
I'm fat.
So, uh...
You have to walk.
Yeah.
I don't think that's how that works.
You're going to just sit on two horses.
Yeah.
T-Gur is just going to say...
How about you just get on top of that one and just relax?
I'm going to get to where mouth has fell and will retrieve them, for sure.
All right, I'll just sit on this bitch, like you said.
All right, Roma, do you want to just knock the fuck out or do you want to say conscious?
I'm going to knock the fuck out, dude.
As Roma just lies on the horse and completely knocks out, T-Gur is going to tie the horse to the news of the other one.
And he's just going to run toward where he saw a mouth has lost.
I'm going to...
What?
You know what?
I'm going to do that for sure on the 20.
Horse is as strong, right?
Let me do plus four.
Horse is in general strong.
You know what?
This horse is going to try.
He's going to buckle down and he's going to run because T-Gur was nice to him.
You was saying something about this?
No.
Okay.
And as at this point, no one knows what happened and you cut to every each and every one of you just bandages all over your body.
You're putting like the rooms that you never used to use.
You were putting those rooms in your ship and you were at the shore.
And you can see here the sea goals and the sea rising.
Each one of you wake up in separate rooms.
I don't know where Bob is, but...
Oh, he was on his way.
Yeah, I messaged him.
I was like, yeah, I think you can join now.
Okay, let's do a roll of fate and see who's turned.
It is.
I don't have a...
I mean, that's not all of the only difference you have the highest.
Yeah, just roll a 1D20 and we'll see.
What?
Oh my god.
You...mouth just wake up screaming as you just remember yourself last that you remember is just this building falling apart and you losing consciousness and you don't know what has happened to Baptiste at this point.
There's no one in your room.
Yeah, I don't know your room.
So I just...just go on and step outside.
Okay, as you step outside, you just see in the living quarters, everyone's rooms just locked up.
Like not locked up, like this, the doors are closed.
There's dead silence on the ship.
You have no idea what's happening.
I can look in the other rooms, I guess.
Okay, can you roll a 1D202 for me?
Well, I think I'm first going to look for Baptiste, but I don't always do me a son.
Yeah, again, you have no idea because you'd never had this conversation of assigning rooms or whatever, right?
Just roll randomly in whichever room you enter.
Okay, the second room, as soon as you open the room, Roma, you're up. What are you doing?
Well, if I just see Roma snoring, I'll...
Alright.
I'm going knocked out.
You hear animalistic noises coming from me, okay?
Roma, you seem surprisingly not that hurt, except for like a little bandage around your chest, but that's about it.
Yeah, that was... oh, it's fine.
Okay, as you walk in the other room, that room is empty.
And you see one more room at the end of that hallway, near the end, toward the back.
Into that room.
Okay, as you go inside that room, you just see Baptiste, like completely covered in bandages from head to toe.
His breathing just heavy, but he is sleeping.
If I see his like stable-ish...
He does seem to be recovering.
It's just going to be a while before he wakes up.
Like that first head of nerves has slightly calmed down, so you'll see on the deck if anyone's there.
You get outside and you just see your ship is not on the sea, but it's like...
It's put toward like the sandy part of the docks essentially.
It's just beeched.
It's not in the sea anymore.
For some reason.
And you see a small like fisherman boat right along where your ship was initially.
And you do see some people on top of it.
Hello.
Not after them.
Are those the other crew?
You can fly over, you can check.
You can't make it out from this far.
Yeah, I'll go over.
Can you make a deck check?
You want to fly or do you want to just jump down and go on feet?
Oh, walk over.
Okay.
As you jump down from the ship, the landing is painful because your bones are kind of hurting,
because they've been through a lot.
As you're walking over, you do see dravos in the corner and he just...
Come on.
There's some people here.
About this.
You know what?
We're gonna shout out anyway, so you can come on.
He takes this one guy with glasses.
He has this black coat on.
As he nods to you, he jumps down and he starts to walk with dravos into the town.
Like the village in the corner that you first arrived at, they're walking toward there.
As you jump on top of the ship, you see a person that you think you've seen before.
You get the feeling you've seen before, but you've never actually met him.
He turns back to you as he's like doing some repairs on the ship.
He turns back to you and goes, "Oh, I assume you're from the other crew, right?"
My name's Chaco.
What's your name?
Mal, who?
Who is this?
This is the first time you've seen a fisherman.
Not the first time, like the second or third time, because you were in the Renzo's crew,
but you haven't met any more fisherman than Renzo.
It's just kind of weird to meet this guy.
He is a red and blue skin color.
He seems to be like a crustacean type.
He has these armor around his shoulders and back.
What are you saying?
Who carried us?
Oh, that was... I forget the name, actually the boss is kind of looking at him.
He seemed to be in a rough shape.
He was the only one, and he seemed to be just carrying each and every one of you near the ship at the end.
Must have been tough on him.
Dude just collapsed as soon as he got to the shore.
He seems to be recovering.
He's still looking at him.
Where is he?
Right around, if you go down from here, he points at like a hatch in the boat.
Oh, just over there.
Watch your head.
Captain usually bumps his head as well.
Make sure.
Yeah, I'll go down the hatch.
This is a very small fisherman boat.
It may be like carries at most six people.
As soon as you land it on the thing, you do feel like it's shaking a bit.
As you go down, you do see the height of the ship is very small.
Especially when you go inside, you have to hunch to even do anything.
Inside, you just smell like all this blood and just screams from one of the rooms.
And in one of the rooms, you see lights.
Which room do you want to go in?
Oh, shuffle towards the lights.
Okay, you ignore the rooms with the screaming.
You shuffle toward the light and as soon as you get inside, he goes, "Shakho."
Oh, it's you.
Come on, take a seat.
As you enter, you see this huge, like, mussely dude.
And he seems to be even like bigger than you.
But he's just kneeling down in front of this small bed.
In front of him, it just looks small.
And he looks as you go.
You have a good crewmate right here.
He carried you all here on his own.
You should be proud of him.
Who's... who are we looking at?
You are looking at Fendris.
Let me show you his...
Let me know when you can...
No, no, no.
No, you're looking at Fendris and he's washing over T-Gore.
And this is the guy that you're looking at.
You have a fly T-Gore carrier.
Yeah, T-Gore carried all of you on his own to the shore.
All three of you.
Bob was carried here by the other two people that left initially.
And you see this small monkey climb around.
The whole like room.
And as soon as he gets near you, he just melts you and just runs off again to Fendris
and just gets on his shoulders.
He goes, "There, there, there guy.
Don't you worry, they're friends."
I suppose.
My name's Fendris.
What is yours?
Melfus.
I'm going to give you a bit of time with your crewmate here.
I'm going to take a look at the other one.
Just wait on the deck once you're done here.
We don't want any more people here than necessary.
He shuffles like a bit.
Go ahead.
Was it very nice to know about this?
Sorry.
What's the damage on the beast?
Well, seems to be some hemorrhaging.
He mostly dealt with it, but he has to lie in bed for a couple of weeks.
He's going to be conscious in a bit, I think, once he sleeps it off,
but he can't move, at least for a while.
I looked at him, but there seems to be no way to bring his wings back, at least for me.
I hope that brings some consolation.
He's going to be just fine.
He shakes your hand, puts a hand on your shoulder, as he just kind of shuffled away and out of the door.
He looks back at you and goes, "I'm sorry, but maybe I can't even say that the other one is going to live.
We're going to try, but at this point it's just up to him."
No, he's resilient, probably.
I hope as well.
He shuts the door and he walks out.
As he shuts the door, Tegor kind of wakes up,
and he gets up, puts his back on the headrest of the bed, and he goes, "Oh!"
He grabs his ribs, and you see a bunch of bandage around his head, around his torso.
He goes, "Malphus, you're right.
You're not hurt.
I'm going to be fine."
I was about to eat.
He was in rough shape.
I was captain.
He says he'll live.
He'll build a group.
Good.
Any news on Bob?
I couldn't ask them on bottom.
Complicated.
Anyway, he was a little fine, too.
Thank you.
I hope in the beginning, maybe I wasn't putting in my words, but I'm going to make it work.
You would also listen to Bob.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah, thank you.
He's just going to go lie back in and pull the blanket on himself and goes away.
I'll go back outside then.
As you go back outside, you just see the small monkey that was waiting, and he just looks at you.
And he snares.
I'll ignore the monkey.
Okay.
You'll ignore the monkey, start to tiptoe around him.
And he just points his eyes at himself and then adds you.
Like the two eyes is giving you that.
All right.
The screaming is still happening, by the way.
Don't think Malfa is looking at the thing.
He's not his ship.
He doesn't know what's going on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, he did tell you to get out as soon as possible.
He doesn't want a lot of people.
Okay.
You go back to your own ship.
Roma can make a wisdom check with advantage.
Oh, my God.
You're just not the fuck out for the next like four to five hours.
Okay.
Is it a long rest?
Yeah, everyone is has long rested.
You don't know how long has it been since you were unconscious.
It's a new day for sure.
Is the break of dawn.
Okay.
You get back on top of the ship as you see Shaco just carrying a bunch of log.
And he puts it down and he goes.
And he's going to be able to recover, you know, at least like three days.
How do I get out of the ship?
Well, it was weird.
We tried to make some repairs.
We saw some breakage in one area.
And we removed the math a couple of times and the ship started floating away.
So we just beasted it.
So something's wrong with that ship and you should probably get it checked with someone who is more experienced than me.
To me, it just looks like this ship has a mind of its own.
Anyway, good luck.
I hope everyone of your team recovers soon.
And I hope the other guy who's been screaming for the last three days.
Stop screaming at the where least.
He does that.
Okay.
Well, we have some people on the way to the island.
And should we deliver some news to what's his name?
Riff.
He came by a couple of times to check up on you guys.
If he comes by again, you'll save your awake.
I don't know.
I have a post and Carla have just left.
They can deliver the message.
I have a dendon moushi.
I can deliver the message to them.
If you have anything, let me know.
You can let them know where we will.
You will have.
Okay.
Anything you need from the town, food, anything?
The moment Roma comes away, I'm sure you'll be hungry.
We did find some supplies on your ship.
I hope you don't mind.
We took some because we were running out, especially with everyone almost dying.
facade.
We don't need payment for your healing.
We don't need payment from the same crew.
Come on.
Do you think of captain is that kind of man?
Anyway, we will pay you back for the rations that we took.
And captain has been a bit busy, so he's not able to cook.
But let me know if you need anything or the living.
By the way, facade should be on the ship.
If you saw him, if you didn't, I'm not sure.
But he was there keeping watch.
I have a question.
You said Riff has come by for the last couple days.
Yes.
Okay, that's all I needed to know.
All right, Melphus.
What are you doing?
Just going through the ship, probably meditate on the mast again.
As soon as you get on top of the mast, you see a guy with like a gas mask on his head and goes,
oh, you're back.
Yes, your best beef.
Yes, my name is facade.
Nice to meet you.
Yours is, Melphus, I presume.
All right.
Well, I suppose I can hand over my duty to you then now.
Is that correct?
Yes.
All right.
No worries at all.
It is my job, after all.
Regarding the man that we took in front of you, he seems to be in a lot of trouble.
Do you happen to know what he uses to power his core?
I'll go to Bob's room and find a little notebook.
Okay.
The one that we just had to find you, whatever, whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
As you go down, facade slowly walks behind you.
As you see him now, you see like a big red canister around his back and like the gas pipe is connecting to that canister.
And you're still just quietly walking.
You hand that book to him.
He goes, interesting.
Yes, he could figure out what it meant.
Lost idea.
Shut down.
You see, well, I'll hand this over to Fendras.
I hope he makes something out of this.
Thank you for your help.
I'm headed out.
Take care.
All right.
He gets up onto the master of the ship and he just leaps off to the other boat.
And that's it.
That's all you see of him and he starts to head down.
And you see just Shaco yelling at him as he lands on the ship.
Run for all right.
Let me move to Bob because Bob's.
Bob's a bit worried.
Still what the fuck is happening.
Bob.
Bob, first of all, what's your what's your final decision?
You had three options, right?
Either you make a new character.
You want to switch it up.
You can switch it up.
Or you want to just come back as Bob.
Back up Bob.
Come back as Bob, dog.
Two of those options he comes back as Bob.
Yeah.
Bob, we can't hear you if you're saying anything.
What the hell is John John?
He goes back as a beaut.
John John someone someone joined.
I'm not sure what I was talking about.
Bobby Bobby boy.
If you're not here.
Yeah, I can hear no.
I don't know what happened with my stuff, but yeah, okay.
So the moment I came here, everyone said someone screaming.
Well, you are screaming.
You are screaming, man.
I'm not sure.
We have, but it's up to you because I don't think that the thing fits.
For like Paladin, we can't use Paladin and we either have to like make the whole someone thing back.
Because Paladin doesn't work with it.
It doesn't have any other brick rules for the subclass.
And we're not going with, I'm just, I just don't want to go with any of the player's handle stuff.
I'm just going to stick with the home group book.
So it's a one day.
So what is it?
Okay.
So you want to keep Bob.
Change your classes.
Want and what was it?
Necromatic.
Mania.
Yes, necrotic.
Okay.
And for necrotic mania, Aminia, if you've read the thing, what was your initial thing?
What was this?
Chaotic good is going to go from chaotic good to chaotic neutral.
Okay.
Just play.
Play him.
Yeah, play him as a chaotic neutral instead of a chaotic good guy now.
Okay.
So Bob, you have some fragments of memories as you were brought to the ship.
The last fragment that you put remember was this spider, like just melding at your core, like this mechanical spider.
The next memory you kind of remember is you flying through this ash cloud surrounding you.
The next memory you remember is this big hand essentially just taking off one of your arms and the other leg.
And the last memory is you inside of this like red cocoon type thing is just glowing from the inside.
All you see out out words is just blood vessels through your chest and everything just leading out words and just you just screaming at the top of your lungs as you feel this like searing pain all over your body.
Okay.
I need you to make three more dead saving throws.
Previous character.
Yes.
This guy already.
Okay.
There are already dead sick failures.
Let me just do it again.
Okay.
It's a success.
That's a success.
It's a fail.
Failure.
Oh my god, Bob.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Fucking.
I'm gonna be a harder dad.
Jesus.
Oh God.
Okay.
All through three days, all that was happening to you is you just slowly see yourself being reconstructed every piece of your flesh just remade.
You are no longer a flesh or like half mechanical, half flesh.
Thing, you are human now for the better part.
Okay.
But there is one thing that's still there, which is your core.
You're gonna be out for another day, but that's your update.
And once we skip one more day, then you can just start talking with the rest people.
All right.
Okay.
Malthus.
What are you up to?
You're just meditating?
Yeah, I'll probably just sit on the top of the desk.
Okay.
Sitting with and reading.
I'm gonna switch to Baptiste.
Baptiste.
It's another one of your dreams.
But this is not seem like a nightmare.
This is one of your happy memories.
It was one of those missions that you completed and you got to talk with the mermaid.
And it's just nice.
It just brings you back to a time where things weren't so complicated.
It was just two of you and no one else.
And you wake up as this ray of light hits your eye.
I guess this wasn't real.
I think it's just a little bit more.
It might still be indigenous from head to toe.
You're banished.
You cannot move your legs.
You're your fractures.
You can't move at the very least.
But you can't sit up on your bed.
I'm not going to sit up.
Okay.
I guess I made it.
In the dark succeed.
You.
Avert your eyes toward the three rings that I've that you have now.
The two fingers that still don't have the rings.
For a couple of seconds your eyes flash.
And you see the hand that it was before.
When it was pointing at Roma and fighting mouthless.
And you feel the worst scenario,
which is you just standing on top of bodies of your friends.
You're crew.
You're just going to keep these rings.
They are danger.
But now I know I can win.
So.
Wherever comes next.
You just got to be prepared.
The new clinch is pissed.
What is can you make a perception check whether to manage.
Okay.
I guess you feel the same energy that you felt yesterday.
The immense pressure that you felt that made you essentially a mobile.
And it rises back.
I'm rushing to that this group.
As you slam the door open,
that piece you see Malfa is just sweating.
Malfa's.
There's like one single tear like.
Leaving that face from when he woke up in this.
Good to see you.
I guess I have you to thank for that.
I'll also help.
Well.
Thank you for this.
It is well.
You define that.
What's the status of everything?
Well, the home is asleep.
Maybe wake up.
Maybe today if you want to.
Okay.
He is on recovery.
He just needs rest.
And they're not sure about.
I guess his.
I'm not sure if he's going to wake up.
I don't think Melvin would be able to draw it on his own.
Yeah, you can draw like a rough shape like Oosop can draw like sorry.
Luffy can draw his flag.
I mean, yeah, essentially I draw draft.
Yeah, you can draw like a draft on a notebook
that you got from fucking your bag or whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure.
Okay.
Oh my god.
How did I have to say that even work?
You know what?
I'm just going to rule it as Roma.
You're going to you're going to feel three days of hunger all together.
Oh, no, no, no, no, I got one better.
Oh, no.
I'm going to wake up.
Sprint off the fucking ship.
Okay?
Because I have three days built up.
You know, when I'm going to go to, yeah, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm going to run into the woods.
You don't see you run.
I'm going to piss.
It is like that scene in white Shakespeare.
He just runs into the bathroom.
Move bitch.
I just starts.
That's all you see.
How that.
No, no, no, no, no.
- Roam is awake.
(laughs)
- Alright, Roam is awake.
You do see Dravos and...
(laughs)
You do see Dravos and Kala at this point coming back.
It's been like a couple of hours
and they have some supplies on them.
Dravos is gonna make like a path
with one of his pipes and gets on the ship
and he looks at you at the mask and he goes,
we brought some supplies if you need some.
Just let me know.
- You can possibly do.
- Yeah, you were at this point, you see the pipe,
you see the pipe leading up to the ship.
- Okay, I'm gonna open the bathroom door and be like,
we gonna need some food, I'll cook it in a bit
and then close the door again.
- Okay, Dravos is gonna put down like a bag of like
just the stuff, meats, vegetables, whatever.
And he's just gonna leave it there and he will head out.
You see the other guy just heads straight to their ship
and he doesn't come on.
- One more question.
- Yes, yes, of course.
- Can any of you throw up?
- Let me, okay, is drawing one of those things
where you need to know how to write or read.
- No.
- I still don't think I can do that.
I'm gonna ask Sir Caller, he is pretty good
at that smart stuff.
Why, what do you need?
- Okay, so can I see it?
- Oh, I'm not.
- I'll make sure this gets to Sir Caller.
Nice to meet you, sir.
Sir, my face, right?
All right, he's gonna head out as the PVC pipes
like collapses back into the ground as he leaves off.
- Now I guess I've just waited an hour
to Roman bidan shedding.
- And you just hear sounds, ungodly sounds.
- It's like a mixture between like the train and service ranks
and fire works.
- All right, a couple hours pass, Roman, you're out.
You're finally done.
- I'm gonna be washing my hands like,
and be like looking at all the stuff he brought from food.
And I'm like, all right, it's time to cook something.
- All right, you head into the kitchen
and you start working on your food.
What are you cooking?
What are you cooking for the crew?
- What kind of meat did he bring?
- He, mm-hmm.
- Just like poultry, not anything fancy.
- Yeah.
- We doin' chicken stir fry tacos.
- Nice.
You start meeting the dough and you start baking,
you start doing all the rest, the kind of stuff.
All right.
I'm gonna say in a couple of more like 30 to 40 minutes,
the food is ready.
And as soon as the food is ready,
you can bring it to everyone, I guess.
Just roll.
Cooks you tensils?
- Oh my god.
(laughing)
- It looks like it tastes like gas.
- It doesn't taste like I burnt the shit out of the chicken.
- Yeah.
- I'm not hungry yet, I'm gonna cook again.
You know what, Roma, you can try again.
You would taste your own food.
You can try to eat it and you can maybe tell
Mouth as this is gonna be a while.
- Hey, hey, it's gonna be a minute.
This is the, I fucked up.
This is, I'm gonna do a cheek.
(laughing)
- You washed your hand.
- I'm gonna go back and get like underneath the nails.
Like.
- That's better.
- Alright, alright, alright.
In a 20 to 40 minutes,
Roma, you salvage some of the stuff
and you start to cook like another like piece of chicken again.
You just have to do the chicken again.
This is, it was terrible, terrible.
And now you have the feast ready.
What do you wanna do with it?
- I'm, you know, like old school,
the fucking bell pounding away on it.
- Okay, I think around this time,
it should be around evening.
And everyone hears the bell, even Baptiste, you're awake.
You're still resting, but you are awake.
Malthus, you hear the bell.
And you do see the lights start to come on,
near the village, and the lights start to turn on
near the other ship.
And you see all of the people from the other ships
start to get to word yours as soon as they heard the bell.
- So, who have played for Baptiste first and bring to it?
- Okay, you grab a plate for Baptiste
and you bring it to him in his room.
- Yeah, I'll knock first, this here is awake.
Come in.
- Oh, go back to the food.
- Thank you.
He didn't go join the others.
- Just try to bring me something.
- Well.
- Alright, Baptiste, what's happening?
Are you enjoying the meal?
What are you thinking?
- Let's do a constitution check to see if I can keep it.
- Oh no.
- This barf of everything.
- Oh God, no.
- No, as soon as you eat it, it sounds, it tastes delicious,
but it's just like your throat is sore.
None of it, none of your body is responding to you at this point.
As soon as you try to swallow a piece,
you just start to throw up.
Malphus, can you give me a perception?
- Okay.
- Yeah, you can hear through the walls.
It's up to you if you want to go in or not.
- Probably.
- Okay, as you hear,
Malphus just cough the food out, you open the door
and you slowly just head inside.
- You want something else?
- No, no, it's fine.
I'll be fine.
- Well, just Roma can probably make a soup or something.
Thank you.
- You take the plate and head out and to Roma.
- Yeah, oh, Roma.
- What a big dog.
- For sure, make a soup for a bad piece.
Don't think you can eat solid food right now.
- I'm gonna look out the ingredients I got.
What do I got left?
- You do have some like stock, some fat left,
some like some of the stuff that you can reuse to make a hot soup.
- Okay, I'm gonna make a lentil soup.
- All right, cool.
- But also,
I'm gonna make a soup, I'm gonna write up a little note
that I'm gonna hang from the bowl.
That says, got my get back bitch.
- All right, you hand that over to Malphus.
Malphus, you take that to about taste.
- Yeah.
- Oh, this version there.
Thank you.
I'll steam the note and read it.
- Cool.
You know, so,
- Yeah.
- Malphus.
But from a note,
I sigh everything.
- What did you say?
- I saw everything.
- You know he's not gonna shit out about this.
- I still got my get back, that's all that matters.
- All right.
All right, as you head out of Malphus,
I guess you convey that to Roma.
Roma,
as soon as you like rang the bell,
all of this happened, Malphus came back.
In the meantime,
as soon as Malphus left with the first plate of food,
you see all these people that you don't know,
except for a couple, which is Draivos.
And I think that's about it.
I don't think you met any of the others.
You see Draivos head up and behind him,
you see this huge guy with a monkey on his shoulder.
You see a fisherman,
you see a small around like five, five, eight guy
with glasses just head up.
And he has this thing around his back.
You don't know what this thing is,
but it just has it wrapped.
And he also has a cloak on.
And you see a guy with a like gas mask,
and another guy with like sleeveless shirt on top,
like black shirt,
as they're like just starting to come onto the ship.
And that's where I'm gonna be like,
(laughing)
and who the fuck would you be?
Roma will be the major ones that heal this up.
What?
I'm sorry, they're the ones who heals us.
He heals us up.
From what?
From you I'm also dying.
Last I remember I rolled down some stairs.
And how do you think you got from the stairs to here?
I have no idea halfway down the stairs.
I was out.
I rolled down some stairs.
Like I was out, I passed out.
They're all so far from black.
So.
The big guy essentially just leans in towards you
and he just puts out his hand and he goes,
"Hi, my name's Fendras."
And you must be the cook of the ship.
And that's what I'm gonna turn to spatula in hand.
I like you, damn fucking right, now how can I help you?
Well, I wanted to see if you were willing
to share some recipes.
I've been struggling a bit.
I like to cook but I don't get enough time in practice.
I hope you can guide me.
Oh, I'll definitely try to but I have a question for you, sir.
Yes, yes, go ahead.
Do you happen to know what palleted or a master chef?
Well, I'm a chef but I'm a cook.
I won't call myself a chef but what exactly are you looking for?
What's a paladin?
I have no idea.
I was just told to find one by a monk guy
'cause I'm looking for somebody as he says,
he told me to attune with a pan.
You need a...
I'd say maybe Kala can help you with stuff like that.
He has these little seashells that he uses to,
you know, on his weapon it makes it work better.
I don't know how exactly it works but who might have say,
I do weird shit too.
Um, you go ahead and talk to him for me.
I gotta get back.
Oh, he's right there.
Whenever you are free, just feel free to talk to him.
He points through the guy with the glasses on.
He just nods at you and goes, that's it.
So what?
I feel like, I'm like, you don't hang out in the kitchen.
I'll be right there.
And then we can talk.
'Cause I'm a chef.
I don't ever stop.
I always be thinking, new shit.
We got some meat back there.
I might salt up the curd, you know what I'm saying?
Like, we might get some...
Okay, should we take that as an invitation to eat?
Oh, y'all hungry?
Why didn't you say something?
Yeah, well, we've been busy.
I haven't been able to provide my crew
with proper meals.
All right, let's go.
Hey, hold me with the...
Fenris, Fenris?
Fenris, yes.
All right, me and you, we gonna go in the kitchen,
we gonna knock some shit out.
You gonna knock some people out?
Yeah, yes, of course, of course.
I would like to learn.
Yes, of course, of course.
We will be putting our work.
If you need anything from my crew, let us know.
Awesome.
All right, he not said everyone at the crew,
and he goes, just try to not make too much trouble.
All right, I'll be back.
As he starts, yeah.
You got somebody who can play some music?
We gotta get, we gotta make this shit apart, you bet.
Um, I, I, I, uh,
drove those plays things, but I don't,
I don't think you'll, you'll enjoy what he plays.
What do you play?
You know what, fuck it, it's whatever, right?
Let him play, why not?
Dribbos, go at it.
You have my permission.
He just says that and he starts following you
back in the kitchen.
All right, we gonna knock out some food.
So I got, I got chicken.
Mm-hmm.
You said some stuff to make some soup.
Oh, we just had chicken stir fry tacos.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, let's mix this up.
Oh, like a chicken Caesar salad.
All right, I, I think that would be helpful
because he's got his neat protein, a lot.
(laughs)
Protein.
Yeah.
He starts chopping up vegetables for you
as you're trying to stir fry the chicken,
or whatever you need to do to make.
Why are you just gonna grill it?
You know Caesar's it up.
We don't want to do it.
Do it with, do it with advantage
because he's helping you.
Just roll again, just roll again, we'll pick the higher one.
Come on, why does it, it won't,
it says there's an axe.
Goddamn, there we go.
What do I, I don't know, sometimes it's just fucking stupid.
Oh, it's 16, the place is better.
Okay.
As you prepare the meal,
and maybe about like 20 minutes since like,
mouth is came in, you handed him the tank,
while you both were working in the kitchen.
All of that passes, everyone's out on the deck,
and there's like this big spread,
everyone's taking from the middle plate,
everyone's eating, everyone's hanging out.
Who's with who right now?
I got the seashell dude,
'cause in the kitchen with me, 'cause I, while I'm,
No, no, not the seashell dude, the huge dude.
Yeah, I also wanted the seashell.
The captain.
So I can talk to him while I'm making food with the,
Oh, not the seashell dude, that's, that's a collar.
Let me show you his image.
Oh, that's a different person.
Let me show you his art.
So you'll have a better understanding.
This is him.
The log around his back is like tied up,
so you don't know, and he's very in cloak,
so you don't see his wings.
Okay.
Yeah, but yeah, so you're talking him,
talking to him in the kitchen,
Malfus, during the thing, who are you talking with?
No, you have to be around someone.
(laughs)
Yeah.
Who's left?
Let me, let me actually just bring all the tokens in,
so everyone has like a visual aid as to who's who,
and what's what?
No, I'll talk to Kala.
Who's Shaka, I mean.
Shaka, okay, let me bring the lunar folds as well.
Map teased.
Roma.
And Bob, what the hell?
You're just not here.
Are we supposed to have?
Are you not seeing shit?
No, no, I'm still on the game verse.
Oh, let me move you to demo.
Here we go.
I can't just, there we go.
And there we go.
You know, I'm gonna just...
Yeah.
Just say everyone's out here.
Oh my God, I'm gonna just remove the fucking wall, man.
Why do I do things?
(laughs)
Fuck you, okay.
Exactly.
Okay, I'll say, yeah, you should be around here.
You should be around here.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Just go into like the main area.
And I'm gonna bring Shaco here as well.
I'm gonna go in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna move a friendress here.
This guy's gonna be in a corner with facade.
And you here and Fendress is gonna be near helping around.
And Vex is just gonna cause trouble in the kitchen.
Bob, you're just on a different ship.
All right.
Okay, what do you wanna talk to color about?
Roma.
So I talked to this old man in this village on this island.
He said, you can do things to my pain.
He called attuning to it to make it better.
Do you know anything about that?
He said, I need a palleted or,
I don't know what a palleted is, by the way,
or a master chef.
Well, no, master chef, but if you need help with attuning your pan,
you said you use the pan as a weapon.
And then you cook food in the same pan.
I cleaned it.
You think I'm a savage?
No, of course, of course not.
I just wanted to make sure that I'm gonna eat the food
from the same pan or not.
It's good to know.
I can help you increase your weapons durability.
Whatever you need, yeah, I can help you.
Just leave off the pan for a couple of days with me.
I'll bring you back to you when I'm done.
Do you need a couple of days, dog?
Well, it's gonna take time.
I have to polish it and it has to be in certain conditions
for a while.
If you cook while that's happening,
I don't think it's gonna detune,
and it's gonna stick.
You can use some other pan in the meantime.
I don't worry.
I've been working with everyone's tools for a while.
I think I'm able to do it.
Okay, I just want to make sure you're fully aware.
You're going to take responsibility.
You messed the pan up, but you might die.
I can't.
This was a gift, brother.
This was a gift, okay?
Yes, of course, of course.
I'm gonna take the utmost care of this stainless steel.
Okay?
No, no.
Okay.
Cast iron, brother.
Cast iron, damn, that's impressive work.
Impressive work.
So I'm gonna give this to you.
Yes, yes.
Once you're done cooking, just hand me over that.
I'll actually, I'll grab it in the morning
once you've done cooking the breakfast.
Okay.
Be sure to try,
I'd out and join everyone else.
So do you need any help here?
That's up to you, big dog.
You know how to make some beer?
In our cult, we don't drink beer.
In your cult, you don't drink beer?
No, no.
I was about to say that, but yeah, I don't drink beer.
No.
But you're a pirate dog.
You work.
I am, I am pirate by profession,
but in my religion, we don't drink beer.
Sorry.
Well, you don't have to drink it.
You get served it.
I can't serve it.
Yeah, I can't serve it.
I don't know how to make it.
I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a look around like in front of me
and be like,
I'm interested in,
should to make beer,
'cause I don't want to shift down the beer.
You should.
You should, yeah, you should.
Can you just do, um,
there's a difference between knowing how it's going.
Yeah, yeah, can you do nature?
Can you just do nature?
Hell yeah.
Just normal.
Yeah, I think it also takes a while.
You guys have, probably have the same barrel
that you use back there.
So there should be some wine that you took from last place.
That's what I thought.
If you want to use that.
Yeah, okay, okay.
It was a, it was a wine barrel.
So yeah, you could just point him to the wine barrel
and you can just tell him to serve that.
All right, man, you see that barrel over there?
You don't wheel that over here.
You're gonna start feeling people's cops.
Okay.
All right, no issues.
You all, you all gonna work.
You ain't gonna, you ain't gonna get shit for free.
Come on down.
No, no, of course, of course.
Of course, we're willing to work.
He takes the barrel and just lifts it straight up
and just starts heading out.
As he lifts it, you see like what?
Don't step on my goddamn counter.
I'm sorry about that.
I won't do that from now on.
His feet barely landed on it, but yeah, he did land on it.
So he takes the beer and like puts,
like just starts pouring it to everyone.
He comes to you, Malfus.
Are you gonna take the wine?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, you take a wine, you get,
distributes to everyone.
He puts it back on the counter.
He takes a plate and just starts to remove the chicken
and just dump it all on this guy.
He just takes the chicken off of the salad
and just dumps it off on him and it sits down
and starts eating.
(laughs)
- What the fuck do you think you're doing, sir?
It's a chicken salad sandwich or salad.
- I'm fine just with the salad part.
- Federalist, you won't have to tell your people.
- They don't get to pick the shit off.
- I'm really sorry if this is disrespectful to you,
but he has his beliefs and well,
we have to be receptive to that.
- We need the eyesight of the chef.
You don't do it in front of the chef.
- Okay, okay.
I'll make sure that he understands this from now.
I'm sorry about my cruise behavior.
- If he's doing it to me, he's gonna do it to you
and you're his fucking captain.
So he ain't gonna eat something to captain, sir.
You get what I'm saying.
When you take on the role in the chef,
you take it in the life of the chef, brother.
The life of it.
- Yes, yes, of course, of course.
Yes, yes.
'Cause if you don't eat, you don't drink, you die.
You get what I'm saying.
- Yes, of course, of course.
I know having some dietary needs or restrictions
puts hamper on survivability out in the sea,
but it is what it is.
I can't really make him do stuff.
- You see this monkey starts to run around
and take a little bit of stuff from the ground.
It starts to eat it and he's just running around
all on top of the barrels.
He comes to you.
Get up here.
I'm gonna give him some salad and be like,
you part of his people, you part of it,
you get some too, come on.
- Okay, you hand him the plate
and he just slides it away.
- Am I gonna have to cut, am I gonna have to cut you up?
- Could you do an intimidation?
- On that monkey.
- On the monkey.
- I am pretty good at intimidation.
- Yeah, yeah, oh my God.
- Now what I do, oh my God,
don't you know?
- As you say that, the monkey is just going to jump on your head,
take your hat and run to Fenderist.
As soon as he gets to Fenderist, Fenderist just goes,
no, Vex, give the good man his hat back.
You're not to misbehave with the crew, all right?
These are our people.
The monkey defeated now, slowly walks up to the counter
and gives your hat back.
- I fuck it, naturally I'm just having like,
- Clam it open.
- Yeah.
- Back to fucking.
- Cooking.
He heads back and he climbs on Fenderist's shoulder
and as Fenderist just like nudges his chin and goes,
you don't do that, okay?
Never do that from out on.
Okay, while all of this is happening,
Draveau's was told to do his thing.
So he gets on top
and he just starts to bang like a bunch of barrels
in like a monotone, tone deaf way.
And he just starts banging,
(banging)
(laughing)
- Will it be a group type shit?
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's just going off and everyone is,
I know for no, but at the same time,
they're just ignoring whatever's happening there.
Okay, now, Malthus, what are you talking to Shaco about?
- You know, still like shit, right?
- What?
- I lost a bit of while ago.
So there's a wide light on the path.
- With light.
We see if he can remember.
Or if he does know about it or not,
oh, he does, that might.
- Full of energy.
- You know, I grew up around shipwrites.
My father was a shipwite.
I've heard these stories.
They say that once you have a group
like a special bond with the ship,
sometimes they see the real manifestation of the ships.
So, I mean, it's of course, it's all fairy tales and whatnot,
but maybe there's some kind of explanation.
But you said you just found the ship, right?
- That was always, that's what I was doing.
- Okay.
- It's really weird.
Maybe it's, yeah, okay, sure.
- I'm going to the game,
real world of foreigners, but...
- Mm-hmm.
Oh.
- Yes, for a sign of the carved names in the,
maybe the initials and the helm, maybe they seem to be the owners.
How did you know how they find the ship?
How did Baptiste acquire it?
- And he said that after he was three years back
and they found somewhere there.
- Cheers.
Yeah, well, that's the extent of my knowledge.
Maybe you should try looking into who these people are.
- Right.
So, you are not human, I'm presuming.
If I'm not wrong, I mean, I got some...
- Oh, I'm looking.
- And that I'm like, what may choose to, you are?
- No, of course, but fishermen are known.
I don't think I've met your kind before.
- That's true.
- And while we were told that Baptiste also had black wings
and those were the signifiers to find you guys,
but when he found Baptiste, it didn't have any.
Yeah, also what's, what the hell is up with those rings?
We tried to get them off, but they just,
it would just like stuck on them.
- Just to make sure we were dealing with...
- No, okay.
Well, you should probably fill in the captain
on these things, but let's try to have a good time
as the...
- Or you have to get...
- Oh.
- What?
- Oh, our paid on both.
- Oh, well, Kate just said that it doesn't,
he just needs some sleep.
So I think he's just sleeping and...
Well, the screaming has stopped, luckily.
So hopefully he'll cover some, but...
- I'm gonna have a look.
- Yeah, yeah, feel free to take a couple of,
you know what, I'm gonna come with.
I'll take some food.
- As well.
- I'll go to catch a person like Roma,
okay, got some food for Bob and Kate.
- You said I got food for Bob, bro, he's a cyborg.
Like, what the fuck do they eat?
- It's so jessured.
- What do you think he wants?
- I don't know.
- I'm so old, I don't know.
- I'm just...
- Okay.
(laughing)
- I'm a beauty 40.
- And that's not even the fuel source Bob runs on.
He just fucking pulls oil.
(laughing)
- He eats, oh shit, okay, well here.
Here, let me settle.
- All you have to do is place Bob and Kate.
- All right, as you're leaving with Shaco,
takes one plate off of you as he jumps off,
and you follow him.
You are off to the boat.
At this point, Fenerys is going to walk up to you Roma
and goes, right then, could I meet Meptis?
I hear that he's awake.
I have some things to talk to him about.
- Can you see him out in the boat, Big Dog?
- Could you just point me to where his room is?
- I can't do that, Big Dog.
I'm the chef.
I gotta make sure everybody's all right.
If he ain't out in the boat, I mean he ain't all right.
- Well, he has plasters on his feet,
so he shouldn't be out in boat.
If he's out in boat, that's the problem.
- I'm just exactly.
- Okay, okay, you know what?
Can you just point me to where your restrooms are?
All of this go and find them?
- They off the ship, they're like,
you see that nearby little storage shed over there?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's where they're at, but I'm gonna tell you right now.
Maybe better if you could just went out in the ocean
because I blew that bitch up.
- I don't think you can see it.
- No, not the restroom rest, I just said bedroom,
I meant bedrooms, sorry.
- Oh, okay.
You're looking at it.
- Okay, okay, I'll just go and figure it out.
Okay, thank you.
He.
- We only got one bedroom, bro, it is the cap.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's gonna leave and Baptiste, you hear a knock on your door.
- I'm sorry.
- Okay, you see this giant man,
even bigger than Malfus enter
and you see like a small monkey around his neck
as he steps in, he says, oh, there we go.
I'll try to sit up.
- Okay, as you sit up, he sits like on the floor
to get to your like eye level at this point and he goes,
now, please, my name's Fran Fenderis,
I am the one that bandages you up
and I hope you're feeling a bit better.
- Well.
Still hurting a bit, but thank you.
- All right, look, I know it's, it's too early
but I need to talk to you about some things.
We are low on time and we need to make decisions
and by the way, I am the captain of the other crew.
Mira sent us to find you because, well,
she was worried that Rias might try to pull something
and well, there was an open bounty on him as well
so we need to collect it and she said the Thompson tried
to get in contact with you but he did
and then we should cut off so she was a bit worried
nonetheless.
She sent us as a backup, we weren't really doing much there
anyway.
So here we are.
She already had plans to send us anyway,
so I think it's best that we arrived.
- So what do we need to get done?
- Sure, you already know that one of the commanders
right hands has been taken prisoner by the Marines
and he's going to be either for two execution
or sent to him pull down,
whatever the situation may be, we have to get him back.
He's our only clue to all of the disappearances
of the old man and the second fleet commander.
- Doesn't sound like that's the only thing we need to get done
based on your tone.
- Yes, well we have another concern
that probably concerns both of us.
From what I heard, you had been traveling
with two of the six falls for some time, yes?
- Yes.
And you arrived just after another one of your crew,
the dreadnought took down Kiro, correct?
- Correct.
- Well, the info that we got in Kiro
was through this man called Linus
and he used to be the part of the six falls a while back.
He left for some reason or the other regardless.
His payment was twofold.
One was just straight up bellies
and the other was finding man called the Clindie Davis.
Not sure if you've heard of him,
but that was our mission.
We were supposed to get travaux,
get to the south blue and find this man called travaux.
I'm sorry, Clind.
- I've heard of him from Wilnitz, Erica,
when they were with us.
- Okay.
Well, the captain's orders stay true,
no matter what.
But if we get a confirmation from you
that deed is done,
then we can get back to Mira
or we can go after him.
It's up to you.
Look, whatever your decision is,
whether you want to go toward
calligos or you want to go toward Clind,
I'll leave it up to you.
First thing in the morning, travaux will probably
at this point still not be able to open the tunnel.
But maybe a couple of weeks from now,
you should be ready.
And I think we all need some rest before we head out.
But the decision has to be made
and Mira needs to be informed.
So I'm gonna leave it to you.
Anything else you need?
Let me know.
- Thank you.
- All right, also, the man that bought you here,
T-Gore.
- You're not taking him from my crew.
- No, no.
Don't worry, he's an excellent crewmate.
And I'm sure you're proud of him
for doing what he did.
But he shouldn't be pushing this hard.
His feet were bleeding.
His ribs were almost collapsed by carrying the Roma,
was it?
I think you need to have a conversation with him.
He's just a kid.
Just take it easy on him.
Anyway, I shouldn't meddle in your business, but just,
let him know that you're seeing him.
That his efforts are being noticed.
That's all.
- I'll keep it in mind.
- He gets out and the monkey will at this point
just look at you and he just snorls again
as they're stepping out.
- I know, I'm so lucky, you little monkey
I used my freaking weight power to wipe you out.
(laughing)
- Yeah, at this point, Fenderis is gonna just stop
the drave from banging on the fucking things.
Roma, cooking's done, everything's done.
You can join in with the rest of the crew if you want to.
- I won't be asking about the town.
- We just fucking demolish their whole civilized
system basically.
- Who do you wanna talk to?
Who do you wanna talk to?
- Whoever's near the bar, 'cause I'm gonna have to start
cleaning the bar and shit and need to clean the bar.
- All right, Carla is at this point just sitting on the bar
near you on the countertop and he goes,
oh yeah, what was the name?
- The guy who's in charge supposed to be in charge now.
I was leading the rebellion.
He has not, yes, yes, riff.
He came by, he gave us some updates.
He said someone named soprano is missing
and a couple more of the noble leaders are missing
but other than that, they have everyone imprisoned
and the rebellion went well, according to him.
They didn't have many casualties.
The noble district seems to be completely destroyed.
One by the collapse of the broadcast hour
and the other by some unnatural force.
We haven't looked into it that much
but yeah, that's all the updates we got from him.
- Can you clarify what you mean by unnatural force?
- Well, there was these torn apart buildings,
like claw marks and just, you know,
buildings toppled over but we don't know how it happened.
You can tell, say, what devil of fruit do you have?
- I have no idea.
- Okay, I mean, by my guess it would be somewhere
around the wolf fruit.
Do you always keep this on?
- Keep one on.
- You, you on.
- Okay, the boat, he just drops it at this point.
He goes, never mind, just forget about it.
And he moves on.
If you have any other questions or...
(murmuring)
- Dumb, huh.
- We gotta get more shit.
- Get a little bang.
- It was a bang, what the fuck?
- No, you're fang.
You were supposed to give it to him when you were done cooking.
- Oh, there, the pant, no, no, in the morning,
you said in the morning.
- You were doing breakfast.
- Yeah, after the breakfast.
So it's still like evening, whatever, right?
There, you're having just like a big feast or whatever.
He, at this point, he's just gonna leave you
and walk up to Fenderus and they start talking about something.
All right, I'm gonna go to Malfus and Shaco.
Shaco is just gonna bring you to the small boat
and you both get on top of it.
He leads you down.
And he goes, okay, which one should do you wanna go to?
- Let's do both.
- All right, I'm gonna take the food to the other guy then.
Okay. - Okay, there, thank you.
- All right, he takes the food plate to
T-Gorsroom and you had inside the
what you see inside is just like a blood bath,
just blood pulling everywhere.
And just, you see this like blood cocoon right in the center
and through the like membrane of that blood cocoon,
you can see like Bob's face inside,
just eyes close completely and that's it.
- We'll put the food down, actually I'm somewhere
and then sit down.
- Okay.
- So Bob, hopefully we did it this time
for the resistance secure.
Anyway, you better get the pick of the fuck up again
or we're just going to replace you.
- Why is this so sad?
- I don't know if it is.
(laughing)
- My ass should just halt dead.
- Yeah.
- You're dying in front of him.
- Oh, put down the next one.
Maybe that way.
- Nope, nope, nothing.
- Even.
- Yeah, as you're like saying all of that,
you just hear the sound as the door closes
and you see the guy with the,
who was like turning into ash and everything
and basically essentially in the beginning
operated on Bob and he goes,
"I wouldn't have such a hope for him."
He seems like the weak kind.
I don't even know why he's here.
- Two weak ones are the one
that goes for pushing there.
- He gets trapped.
- Bob.
- This cover does is something else.
Call him this part.
- It's supposed so.
And he was facing that beast on his own.
I should commend him.
- He's trying to push me into that room.
Well.
- No, okay.
- What we did?
(laughing)
- I guess he's more smarter than I gave him credit for then.
I just thought he's one of your demo assets
who just walks into fights with no taught in their mind.
Anyway, I should probably keep an eye on him.
You can head out now.
- Tell me in a bit the moment you accept him.
- All right.
- I'll go see Tigger again.
- Okay.
You walk into the room and Shaco is telling Tigger
about these crazy animals that he is encountered
in his travels and he's just ranting about that
as you head inside.
They turn and look towards you.
- Did I hear Mermaid?
- No, no.
- You're a rest of well?
- Yeah, yeah, I think I'm good.
Maybe I should be able to walk around.
Melv's is a few, don't mind.
I wanted to go to the forest and maybe look for some animals.
- You need to rest.
Here's the Mb back.
Better shape.
- Oh, okay.
- 'Cause this small part of the higher up's left
and if you walk around, my cost travel.
- All right.
I just didn't wanna cause any more delays than there.
- Don't push yourself.
Yes, that's how well.
I'll keep that in mind.
We gave our work to your brother.
- Well, is this brother?
- Yeah, it was his brother.
- We gave your work to your brother,
that we would keep you safe.
- Yes, I appreciate it.
- I think I got it from it.
- Thank you.
Shaco gets up, kind of stretches and goes.
So, Melv's you, you wanna spar for a bit?
I think you might be the only one who hasn't been.
- I could use all stretching.
- All right.
If you wanna head down to the beach,
maybe we could have a one, two.
- All right.
- All right, as you both head out,
I'm gonna say all night, you were just talking about
like your adventures so far and so far
as you were like sparring with each other
throughout the night.
Baptiste, what have you been thinking
after Fenderes left you?
- How do Fenderes left?
I wanna have written a note for someone to give to Rich.
In the note, it just asked him to find an assortment
of beasts and animals.
- Okay.
So, have like some animals fight alongside him
and Kate can just choose amongst them
or find which one he has the best connection with.
- Okay.
So you have that written down
and you just put it on the bed side.
Maybe someone comes in and takes a look at it.
- I probably, in a morning,
I'll probably like check this one book
just to get into your notes.
- Okay, not good.
Okay.
- Then I'll also tell them,
like if it's gonna take a couple of weeks
for us to be ready to go just to help with the effort
on the island to make sure that border is bored.
- Okay.
- Everything is.
- All right.
- Day, Roma, what are you doing?
You cleaned up the bar.
You wanna talk to anyone, you wanna do anything else
or you wanna just head to bed.
- It's probably, wait a night time.
I'm probably just gonna go, I cleaned up.
- No.
- Just told you about Bob, so I'm just gonna wait it out.
- Like, shit.
- I'm gonna go get some meat here.
Like, go salted up, season it up,
put it in a dry rack,
get it all ready to get dehydrated and shit.
Don't make some jerky.
- All right.
So I'm gonna skip to next morning,
and then we're gonna go to Bob, okay?
All right.
So around like,
maybe like eight or nine-ish everyone had left
onto their own ships.
They have kind of set up a small tent outside on the beach itself
because not everyone can fit on the ship,
especially fenders and everyone,
because their crew has grown from last time.
So some of them are sleeping on the beach
and some of them are on the boat.
And Malthus and Shako, you've been fighting all night,
but you essentially just at some point just knock out
and just lie on the beach, sleepin'.
And Malthus, you wake up at maybe like three or four
in the morning, you head into Malthus' room,
you see his note and you get Shaka-Cala
who had been walking around like writing something
on his notebook.
And he looks at you and goes,
oh, by the way, I got your designs.
I'll see, I'll head into town and maybe get some cloth
and something to paint it over with.
I'll get you your flag by maybe next morning.
Also, I'll--
- I got your movie leading to four days.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I'll talk to the other guy as well,
according to this note, Riff Sin, right?
- Yes.
- Okay.
All right, I'll let him know when I head into town.
- All right.
If any of you want to accompany me,
you will be looking over some supplies,
just equipment and the guy Riff also said
that the armory was open for us to use
if we needed anything.
- I'll go with you.
- Okay.
I'll head out in--
Yeah.
- Hey, grab me some jattlers.
- All right.
He says, okay, how about this?
Meet me in about four hours.
We'll head into the--
I'll get some stuff done on the ship
and then we'll head into the town.
- All right, also get supplies for the boat.
We're gonna need some more food.
- Yeah, yes, of course, of course.
He's just gonna head back to his ship.
And yeah.
- Baptiste, you're awake and near like in the morning,
you do see like a small wooden chair.
Like a wheelchair, along your bed.
And it just says by your favorite ship ride check-up.
- Then how are you gonna get to the wheelchair?
- You can get it.
I think you can not push yourself too much,
but you can get in the wheelchair.
- Just put it on the floor, just corner,
for wherever--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Baptiste, at this point, you can head out into the outside.
Because you are in the captain's quarters,
just before and there's like four small rooms
and you're at the backmost one.
So you can head out onto the deck and you can see
what's been happening.
- The Bay 3.
- This is, no, three days after you've already fought him
and then one day after fourth day.
This is the fourth day.
- Yeah, I'm staying in bed until week one is done in 30.
- Okay, on the next day, when that happened,
you wanna head out and meet Riff, Malthus?
- Yep.
- Okay, Malthus, you head out with color
and you head into the initial village that you saw
and you see people already got rid of
like the big giant board that was this place
and this place, how it used to feel
when you first arrived here is very different
for how it feels now.
The children's running around playing
and the adults trying to rebuild,
trying to just fix the door that Roma broke
at one of the houses and just like all of the railings
along side the village are being taken down
and everything, you just see like how much it has changed
in only like three days.
As you start moving inside, you see like those jelly fishes
that you initially saw in like the water,
they've just disappeared at this point.
You don't see anything, the fog has lifted out of the lakes
and you see like people going in for water or whatever
and bringing them, bringing it back.
You see carriages, you see people bringing in supplies,
all this stuff and you're still like walking
right along color inside the gate.
You do see some like the same rope that the communers were wearing.
Those people are guarding the door
and one of them just looks at color and he goes,
"Oh, welcome."
Should I send some word to Master Riff of your presence?
He looks at you, Melfus and who the, who might this be?
Color introduces you as
he is the one that seemed to have been in one of the Summars Five.
As Riff told me, the guy just looks at you.
Oh, you're one of the,
one of the people who helped Master Riff, of course, of course.
I should just lead you straight to Master Riff then.
Just follow me.
You start to follow this guy through the like slums
which are now being like fixed,
like all the broken buildings, the houses with like the hay on top,
the hay is being taken off and people are like putting stuff
on the roofs that make them more durable, stuff like that.
And you basically had down the same alley
that you first met,
what's his name, I fucking riff in.
And the house that was like completely torn apart and broken
is now completely fixed as the guy knocks on door
and he just tells the guy behind the door
that someone important is here to meet Master Riff.
He opens the door and the guard looks at you, Melfus and goes,
we are very grateful for your assistance.
And I don't know how to say this,
but what you've done, I saved our people for a lot of pain.
Thank you.
Hey, you bows and you just starts to leave.
Kala at this point, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I was just gonna say,
yeah, I'll enter the house for him then.
Okay.
Kala at this point, just like elbows, you can go,
fucking heroes.
All right.
Good job.
He steps inside and he goes,
well, I'm gonna go gather some supplies.
You just talk to him and let him know
when we're about to leave and whatever you need to do.
He, as soon as you get inside around the room,
you see Riff in like the, he's dressed very differently
instead of his like rugged leather shirt pants and all of that.
He's like dressed like, I don't know, an aristocrat with like a suit on.
He has like this tie on and his hair is well kept
and he gets out and he goes, Melfus, how?
I'm so glad that you were okay.
How is, how are the rest?
Will it?
Okay, come on, head inside.
Just take a seat.
Hey, can you bring in some,
something to drink from Melfus?
Just, just be quick.
We have to head out pretty soon.
He invites you in, he invites you to sit on like one of the desks
and he, you look around, it looks like pretty, like all,
pretty and whatever, you know, like decorated and stuff.
And he goes, yeah, look.
What?
What the next step for design?
Well, for now we're just trying to rebuild.
We're just trying to move people from the slums to maybe the noble district,
but even the noble district is torn apart.
So he had to make some repairs.
But it is better than we thought the jaw locks were
off as soon as the building collapsed.
And of course, I couldn't have done it without you, or cadence,
or any of these people really.
Just after you guys left, it is our troubles.
And we should have been able to deal with it.
And I'm not gonna say it was easy,
but we were able to push back the remaining guards and soldiers
that the nobles had.
And thanks to whatever torn apart those buildings nearby,
the armies were nothing.
They were left ruins.
Just, you know, anyway, so yeah, we're doing well.
I'm just happy that you're all doing well as well.
I hope.
I have this note for you.
- Oh, ring me around like I'm one of his lackeys.
Yeah, I'll make sure that I'll send some people
to gather some of the animals from nearby.
What is it for anyway?
- It's for paid.
- No, the guy with the tiger mask.
- Oh, well.
- He has his own mission, his own goals.
And I would like to.
- Yeah, I'm ashamed to say it,
but I feel like he's much better than a fighter than I am.
He went down in that fight three times
and he got back up each time with my brother,
with my cousin, with him.
Was it sent?
I don't remember fucking, I don't care.
And he goes, it's unfortunate that I had to do that,
but it was, I couldn't let him live like that.
He lost all of his senses.
I don't even know what the hell that was.
We never knew about this up until well, you fought them.
I'm sure it was a surprise for you as well.
- It was.
- It was, so you have any idea what that was?
It seemed to be strangely unbothered by it.
- I've come across where things before,
so every I have a secret.
- Well, we found some things in the King's Chamber,
but because of whatever happened to Baptiste,
complete thing was in rubble,
but we were able to find one name.
Maybe it means something to you.
He hands you like this torn apart piece,
this like joined together by tape, and he hands you this.
And what you see next is, I'm gonna just send it to you.
And you can feel free you wanna share this message or no.
This seemed to be a message of some sort
through one of the carrier pigeons from outside,
ground line of course, but I don't know
if it's supposed to mean anything.
- He just sees a side of your evilness base.
- Okay.
He asked you,
do you recognize that name?
- I do.
- Okay.
- And all of a sudden, I guess hope.
- It's good to hear.
Good to hear.
So, what's,
so when can I meet Baptiste?
- I need to thank him in person.
He was the one who take down Coda.
And believe it or not, whatever you face,
he probably faced worse.
- Oh, by later, is that.
- Okay, I'll make sure I'll come by bearing gifts.
And of course, we can't really help you with any of the treasury
because we need that to strengthen ourselves.
But feel free to,
feel free to have a look at what the armory has.
One of my men would lead you to what I need to head up
and talk to these fucking old people.
What did I got myself into?
- If he walks away, I'll just say to them and read.
You just close, don't do it.
- What? Sorry, I couldn't hear.
- Don't close, don't do it, too, too.
- So, I can't, what?
- That is not, that is not the close we're better for it.
It's a more free.
- I get, I see, I see.
Not gonna lie, I hate these clothes.
But it is what it is.
All right, Malfa, I'll see you in the afternoon.
Goodbye.
One of the guards at his door just starts to lead you
toward the new walkway kind of like a temporary bridge
toward the noble district is like in form of like stairs.
He leads you to it and he like gets near like this big warehouse
and he goes, "Fu-Fu-Fu-Fu-Tu, browse, whatever you need."
And if you need any help carrying, let me know.
- All right.
- You head inside.
What are you looking for?
- There is all sort of stuff like, yeah.
- First of all, some javelins for Roma.
- Yeah, you see some javelins in like the corner rack.
- Going?
Yeah, for the future, I don't really need anything
because we just use our fists.
Maybe some like, to all weapons for a...
- Okay, can you make me investigation?
Because this is like large warehouse, it depends
if you can find anything or not.
- Nice.
You walk around like these large racks of just weapons,
maces and all of this and inside like a small corner,
you see like a box of just like gauntlets
with like different hooks that you can attach
and it's just a box filled with like different kind of hooks.
- Add a two shopping cart.
- Okay, you put the javelins as well in the box
and you just lift the box itself.
- Anybody else?
- People won.
- You can make requests by the way outside of...
- Yeah.
- On the tape.
- Above the board.
You can try to look around for a golden spatula, I guess.
- All right, let's go.
Bob and Baptiste over the table,
if you wanna look for something, can.
- The items that I get from like the items
that you start with, start with the Paladin class for flavor,
can we just say, "Malpha gets those"?
- Yeah, yeah, what are those items?
- Armor, then Halbert, Gradyx, and...
- You know, just in case,
Malthus, you start to pick off a couple of armor sets,
not heavy.
- Not probably.
- Yeah.
- It's very heavy.
Oh, very heavy.
One, you get a very heavy armor set
and one, you get for Cade,
who, as far as you know, is pretty nimble and everything,
so you don't take a very heavy piece,
but a medium armor or whatever.
So you just put a couple things in,
you put some couple swords here and there,
if you need them, whatever, right?
As you head back, you don't see anything of note, really?
This is like the general armory,
but you do see like the tuning forks and the guns
and everything that you see,
I've seen like those soldiers carry before,
so if you wanna put some of those in,
you can also do that.
- I would like a cloak of displacement.
- Cloak of displacement.
- Cloak of displacement, how would I flavor?
That's what I, I'm not aware of.
- I can't hold it while you're there.
- Cloak of displacement, let me check.
Well, you wear the cloak at the game's illusion
that make you pure standing in place,
your actual location, causing any creature.
You know what?
Sure, one magic item, what do you need?
Everyone, everyone.
- Do you use a magic item?
- Yes.
- Which rare item?
- Every single one.
- But as long as it makes sense in the world,
that's what you get, that's about it.
- Which rare item?
- Yeah.
- Wait a minute.
Oh yeah, good question, which rare item?
Like uncommon one.
- Which rare item?
Let's just say rare, let's keep it to rare.
- Oh.
- Well, how would I want?
- Well, anyway, let's have a look.
- Just say, as a guest, the staff and people decide later.
- You know what, you know what?
Give me a 1D20, give me a 1D20.
- No.
- Did I not choose?
- No, no, no.
I think that's a bit too much.
- Oh.
- How about we all do 1D20
and then we pick whatever.
- No, no, no, no, no, wait a second.
Magic table A, magic table B, magic table C, magic table D.
No, I can't do that.
It's gonna throw up like the balance.
Can you give me one, two,
- That means you got it all good.
- Wait, give me one sec.
- I.
- You got T's roll of that, calling.
- Okay, can you?
- I'll see if we...
(laughing)
- Got T's roll in that 20.
Oh, he did, he did.
- How old is it?
- Roll my call, let it.
- Do I feel like a level five,
which I've had a user, a rare magic item?
- Okay, let me see.
Can you roll a 1D9 as well?
- Everyone.
- Since I've done the X, what can I just choose?
- You wanna choose from 1, 2, 9?
What do you wanna choose, 9?
- I got a 9.
- Roll 1D9.
- Slash, roll 1, yeah, slash R, 1D9.
Slash R, space, 1D9, sorry.
Okay, so you get 9, okay, nice, 637.
Okay, what was the roll actually?
Can you give me a 1D 100?
- My net 20 was pointed.
- Yeah.
- I'll consider the net 20 as 100, how about this?
- Okay.
- Okay, so good.
- How old is that?
- 98.
- 98, 97?
28, nice, okay.
Can you give me or what did you roll a Roma for the 1D9?
- 1D9 and I rolled the 7.
- Okay, I...
And...
G, okay, what was the, thank, 28?
Okay, 20.
8.
All right, I know what this thing is.
Maybe I can make it work.
All right.
- You're doing some fun calculations.
- All right, Bob, what did you roll for your 1D9?
- 6, 6, 7.
- All right.
- Go on from your Bob, Bob, Bob.
- Oh my God, Bob, you were dead.
Bob, you're being a Bob.
(laughing)
- Sorry, 6?
- Okay.
- If you say 7, I'm gonna kill you.
- Oh my God.
- It's a magic head that obliterates him.
- 69.
- Okay.
What was your thing?
97.
Okay, we got another magic item.
All right.
What did you roll for 1D9, Bob Teased?
Three?
- Three.
- What was the 100?
(laughing)
- Oh, we got something good.
You know, he sighs when we do it.
- Now Bob's gone.
- Let me power.
- Oh my God, this thing,
those things are so crazy.
Jesus.
I'll give you time to figure out what it will be.
But I'll send you the thing in the DMs
what you will get.
But you won't find anything here, Malthus.
You will find like normal stuff here.
I'm gonna let you know how you get all these items.
Okay, Malthus, finally you.
What did you roll?
- Eight.
- Four, nine.
Nice.
And what was the thing?
Ninete.
- Eight.
- Eight damn.
Okay, hope you're shit.
(silence)
- Oh my God.
- Is that a good or bad God?
- Oh my God, this is just too much.
- Nope, you yet know you did right now.
- Oh no.
- Yeah.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh my God, this is crazy.
Okay, all right, I'm gonna send what it is
once the thing happens.
And I'm gonna let you know, I think
you may have to like move stuff around
or like we might need to homebrew it,
but let's keep like the core thing.
Yeah, just the core thing like as is,
like what the purpose of it is,
do we can change the, what it looks like
and whatever, flavoring, and so on.
All right, mouth is you head out,
you take this box of stuff,
do you wanna hand it to the guard
or do you wanna just carry it?
- Oh, carry it myself.
- The guard kinda comes up to you,
but as soon as he sees like the amount of shit you has,
he just puts his back, hands around his back and he goes,
(clears throat)
So we're ready to go then, yes?
All right, let's head out.
He just starts walking fast.
I don't know if you're just so you don't ask him to carry.
- He's gonna be fast.
- What is fast?
- Just fast walking.
Just, I'm just casually walking next to him.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, all right, mouth is you will see color
in between as you start to head toward the ship.
Okay, Bob, it is morning and you find yourself in this,
red liquid, jelly, substance,
aren't you?
You're completely like head to toe,
completely naked inside this jelly.
You have no idea what is happening right now.
- Can I try to check out myself,
can I do any investigation checks or something like that?
- Sure.
- With which character?
Right now, just old, good old Bob.
- Got it.
- Good old Bob.
- Old Bob had better investigation.
- Let's find this one.
With respect based on what happens, you know.
For now, let's just do, just do 1D20.
Just forget about any of the modifiers.
Just think of yourself as an NPC.
- No, 1011.
- I had to pretend that 11.
- Okay, 11 Bob, you can see your arm is back.
Your everything is back,
except for your chest, the core stills is embedded in you.
At this point, but this time,
you can't really remove it.
It's like completely melded into your body.
And yeah, you're stuck, you can't even move,
you're like this jelly-like substance,
but you know what it is, it's just blood.
It's just blood surrounding you.
- Try to scream.
- You can't scream.
- Okay.
- No, no, you have a mouth, but yeah.
But you can try to force your way out of it.
Can you do a 1D20?
- Sure.
- Ooh, nice.
You just like, hold your arm and like try to like,
break out of it.
Both of your like arms upwards as you like, come out.
And you see this guy that you've never seen before.
He stands close to you.
What the fuck am I playing?
Okay, there we go.
It's so loud.
He stands above you and he goes,
oh, look, the sleeping head's awake.
Now, if you would like to calm down a bit,
I would like to examine if you're doing all right.
- He looks at him with like, shake, like,
wide eyes and his body shaking.
He goes, who are you?
- Oh, worry not, I am unfortunately with you.
Now, if you could just give me a moment to check everything
and you're doing okay.
He takes out like these like, status scope
and tries to like get a read on how you're doing.
He asks you to like, open your mouth, show him your tongue.
He like opens your eyelids.
He tries to see the then your eyes.
He goes, he like knocks on your like metal core
and goes, except for this, everything seems to be in place.
So how does this feel to have your arm and leg back?
- It's so weird.
- Well, I'm gonna tell you something
and try not to freak out.
In every sense of the word, you are dead.
You don't have a heartbeat.
The core is what I was listening to
and that's the only thing keeping you alive.
So you are something else entirely.
I'm not sure what.
But congratulations, your life maybe.
How would you describe life?
Do you at least feel it yourself?
Do you have your memories?
I'm Bob.
Hello, Bob, my name's Malik.
Malik Samim.
I am...
- Do you...
Where did you find me?
Did you see three other people?
- Yes, yes.
Your crewmates are fine.
They're on the other ship.
They're doing well, except for your captain.
He seems to be injured from waist down,
but he should be recovering soon enough.
His constitution seems to be very well
considering what kind he is.
So you shouldn't be walking around,
maybe I'll bring you to your ship once you settle.
You can lie in the bed and maybe take some clothes
while you're at it.
He goes all the time, he's like in a trance.
He still thinks that he might...
This might be a dream, so he just follows.
And I lie down, close his eyes and hopes that
he might open them back up and this will just be like
the other dream and he'll wake up at the ship.
- All right, you close your eyes and you just
take a sigh of relief and yeah, you just knock out again.
Around this time, you would have been moved
from your bed on the other ship,
to your bed on the other ship.
You wouldn't have noticed
because you'd really completely blanked.
So everyone from the Lunar Fold crew
has been relocated to their ship.
Only four rooms are there right now on the ship.
So some people are still on their ship, which is T-Gore.
And I guess that's all your crew, yeah.
- Yeah, if you were once, I probably let him in my bed.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
Malfus, you've probably given up your bed for T-Gore,
T-Gore sleeping in yours while you are at the mast still
meditating, I suppose.
- Given Roma is mind of supplies.
- All right, Bob.
I'm gonna skip to maybe about like two or four hours
to the afternoon and around this time,
you see from afar, for the breakfast part,
I think Roma would have made a breakfast,
can you do a roll for me, Roma?
- Oh hell yeah.
- So I just asked him to start charging one of the suits
for her.
- Just right.
- You just want a normal, just same roll.
- Yeah, just same roll.
- Not the same roll?
- Yes.
Oh my God, he was criticized.
- He was getting more.
- He was, he was, oh, it was okay.
I would say.
And as the evening rolls around,
sorry, the afternoon rolls around,
Malfus, you spot like a horse carriage headed to word,
the edge and you see a rift get off
and as he get off, he puts his hand towards the carriage
and he brings down someone that you know,
but she's dressed a bit differently
as she gets down and starts to follow rift onto the tank.
And rift just says to the people on the carriage
that just, he just signals them and they start to come down
as they tie the carriage around the trees.
And yeah, he's climbing on the ship
as he pulls cadence now that you can see up.
Yeah, he's on the ship.
Malfus, I suppose you're flying down,
you're jumping down.
- Oh, just go down and read him.
- Okay, as you go down, you see, he goes.
- All right, well, I'm here and well, like I said,
I have a brain presence and now I'm gonna send you
the things that you had.
- Quassan.
- Quassan, you fought some Quassan.
Check your DMs, check your DMs.
I don't know how you'll make it work, but it's crazy.
I think it's weird, but it's crazy.
(murmuring)
You have to reflavor it in some way
that you can make it work, but that's up to you.
- What is this?
- You see, I wouldn't work 'cause I wouldn't need
an other item.
- What do you mean?
- Use it on the server.
- You need a sphere of annihilation to do something with it.
- If it's useless, then maybe next time then,
you have this thing, you don't know how to use it.
It's just like decorative as far as you know, for now.
- Well, the thing that I got would be nice
for a party trick, I think.
- Nice.
- So I guess I'm still a wizard.
You wanna keep being a wizard?
- No, no, no.
- Okay.
Okay, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Nice.
Roma, you have some sense of what it is.
- I figured out how I could do this.
You said I got a flavor this, right?
- Yes, yes, just flavor it.
So you know how I have homeboy trying to tune with my skillet,
right?
- Yeah.
I could have it be the ability that he gives.
- Okay, as if you had cast, conjure, element, spell,
the sensor can be used this way again until the next dawn.
So essentially, I'm for Tesla Rosemburish,
Palace, it weighs one pound, summoning.
Okay, it's like a summoning thing
that can summon like error elementals.
- Yep.
- I knew what I cook at it.
Only what I cook at it.
- Okay.
- I could conjure the error elementals
to help me fuck it.
- Cook?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
All right.
Batiste?
You can...
- Can I just find the buyer?
- What?
Let me check what it is.
- Yeah, I could.
- You see?
- I could.
- Let me check what it is first.
It's rare.
While wearing the tank,
you can use the action to open it.
- Yeah.
- Allowing it, allowing the water to weird,
water weird,
I don't know the water weird to emerge.
Water weird acts immediately after you
are initially under bound to the tank.
I'll say you can create like creatures from your void.
How about that?
It's just a thing that you can like,
maybe some use something to channel the void and item.
- Okay.
It doesn't have to be a tank though.
- Like a...
- Is it actually a tank?
I think it's just the water weird.
What is the water weird?
- It's a tin gallon tank of lone gas
and it's hopefully bronze with a backpack
like carrying parts.
- No, no, no, no, no.
You can change that.
- Let's say it's just like a small orb.
The water weird look kind of cool,
little like snakes and like Leviathan's kind of...
- Looks like a Leviathan, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It could be like a mermaid thing
if you wanna riff off of that.
- Oh, okay.
The fork.
(laughs)
- Instead it's gonna be like a void creature,
but it's still a hook.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah.
- We'll figure it out.
- Yeah, if you wanna just treat the item as its own thing,
it can be just water that you can harness
or if you wanna do fire, we can just change it to fire.
It doesn't matter, the fucking same thing.
- I don't think I can't change it.
It's part two of them, like a fire variant of it.
So I'm just gonna leave it as the water weird
and it just like like...
- Yeah, yeah.
- No.
(laughs)
- All right.
So as riff comes in, he hands you
mouth is this like scary as locket and he goes, yeah.
- I'll be discussing something else later
'cause there's no way I'm gonna make the shit work.
Even if I have the other thing, complete use for me.
- You wanna reroll? I can give you one reroll.
- Well, I can, can I just give options?
(sighs)
- Or the same therapy of even lower.
- Sure, let me check.
- Well, sorry, but there's no fucking way
I'm this would ever work for me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
What was it?
Talisman of the sphere, right?
- Yeah, cause if you use that,
you need an older legendary item.
- Yeah, I get it.
Let me check it.
- Oh, wait, how do you like it?
- It's playing the curse.
- Just, just reroll, just reroll.
I'm gonna give you, no, I'm just gonna give you
the same table from the same table, just reroll, the table.
- Just to be on under.
- Yeah, 100.
- Can I reroll as well?
- No.
Cause truly, he can't make it work.
- No, okay, you can, you can make this work either.
There's armor, plus three leather armor, okay, reroll.
- Oh, yeah, that's, that's, have a look at this.
- Let's see, as long as it makes sense.
- Yes, that one good makes sense.
- Shroom Giants says, "A reward is a brave ban
"of small adventures by wearing this crown.
"You have the resistance for lightning and thunder damage.
"If you're subjected to, you can use action
"to release a bolt of lightning at a point on the ground.
"You can see within 16 feet.
"Each creature, you see, thunder wave."
You know what, yeah, he hands you a bracelet.
With this red, like blue gem across it
and he goes here, something that I found in the treasury,
hopefully it helps you.
And we're, where's Roma?
Let me, I have something for him too.
- Follow me.
- Okay.
- I'm going to meet Roma, he'll lead him to the kitchen.
Cadence is gonna stay back on the ship as Riff comes in
and he hands Roma this, what do you want it as Roma?
- Fuck.
- It's supposed to be like an incense thing.
- Yeah, make it like a, oh, I have a question.
Can I change it from like an incense jar
to like a seasoning jar?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can say, you're a monom, I heard you were the cook,
so here's like an ancient jar or something
that I found in the treasury, maybe it helps.
Okay.
And now he's gonna go, well, it's Bob doing well.
- No idea, big dog.
He's away.
- Okay, let me go talk to him.
He adds to Bob's room at this point.
He just says, can you keep Cadence company?
I'll talk to these two on my own.
He goes in, he sits like along the bedside of Bob
and he like taps on your shoulder, Bob.
Bob gets up like with a sudden jerk,
like he's scared of what just happened.
- Okay, first luck stone, my god, man.
- Can it be, I'm gonna be told this year,
so can it just be Bong?
- Like, Bong.
- You hit it, yeah.
- You hit it once and then you are like,
you'll get like full hyper.
And then for the rest of the time, you get ahead.
- While carrying the stone, you gain advantage
on one ability check of your choice.
This stone can't use this way again.
Look, Bob, this is from my old days.
I don't do this anymore, but here, it means a lot to me
and the way that you put yourself on the line
for my sake means a lot to me as well.
So he just hands you a fucking Bong.
- We're think to give someone who just died, but...
- You know, maybe check with your doctors.
I don't know, maybe it helps.
- I really need this right now.
- Okay.
It's fine, Bob, you just take a minute.
And Baptiste, you hear a knock on your door.
- Answer.
- You see, Riff head in again, his tire,
completely different for what used to be.
He enters, he walks up to him and goes,
oh, well, if you had bangs on.
How do you know I had wings?
- I, no, I figured out.
I don't know what exactly you are, but the guy had wings,
so I assumed they were yours.
I don't know what happened in between,
but I saw Malfa's wings and you kind of resemble him.
So...
Anyway, not that it matters to me at all.
I have something for you though.
He hands you like this blue gem type of thing
and goes, this is supposed to be one of the gifts
from a long lost King's relative
that visited a Mermaid Grove.
Maybe you like it.
- Now take it.
- No.
- You're almost there.
I think that she gave you.
- Thank you.
- I should do the one thanking you.
You and the rest of you crew saved our kingdom.
And this, this least that we can do, at least.
I know you're a pirate.
I mean, of course, it's clear at this point,
a new from the very beginning, but...
I don't care what the government or the Marines say.
I think a man's character is described by their work,
by their actions, not who they are.
So...
You have my word that in case you need any of our assistance,
we will be there.
The kingdom of Desibella will be there.
And he extends his hand.
- Thank you.
- He grabs your elbow and he kind of like shoulder bumps you
and he goes, stay safe, friend.
- Take care.
- Also, how about, what are you doing here?
Why are you sulking around?
Come join us.
How about this?
I'm gonna come by this evening,
and we're gonna have ourselves a good old banquet.
Wouldn't that be nice?
- Not someone sulking, it's more...
- And I hear them.
- Yes, you hear banquet.
- So then, I'm like, these motherfuckers,
we just had one last night, now we gotta do it again.
Don't worry, Roma, I'm gonna bring my people to help,
if you need to.
You know what, you just relax, I'll just bring my people.
They're gonna cook, they're gonna do everything.
- Oh no, I cook, my God, then.
Now I gotta come up with what we gonna do.
Hey, what...
What can we make?
Hey, what do you guys got on your ship?
- We have on your ship?
- You think?
- You gotta pick.
- Roma, Rift just walks up to you,
and he puts a hat on your ship.
Don't worry, whatever you need, you'll get, all right?
- Well, shoot.
- All right, Baptiste, what were you saying?
- What was I saying?
- It's not so much a sulking, what were you saying?
- All right, then I just looked at my legs.
- Oh.
It's fine, I'll be with you all the way.
How about that?
- Store.
- All right.
I did, I did, I did, I have my people working on it,
and for your friend, I have another gift,
which is the animals, they'll be arriving tomorrow.
- Thank you.
- Okay.
- All right, that's gonna be his farewell to you, Baptiste,
and while this was happening,
cadence was up top, talking to you, Malfus,
and she goes, she tries to say something
because she hasn't spoken anything since birth.
She's struggling, but what she's just trying to say is,
thank you, and that's it.
- Hello.
- She can seem to convey what she's trying to tell,
but she just finds like a paper,
or like a napkin in her pocket,
and she starts writing down.
- Did I roll an insight to see her face
before she writes down?
- Yeah, sure.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Yeah, she's kind of smiling,
and she writes something down,
and she hands it over to you.
It essentially just says,
I thought I made him happy,
but ever since you guys came in,
he has not stopped smiling,
and I'm grateful that you can make him see the good in people,
and I can believe in what he can do.
So it's not just to save the island,
it's to save us, save him.
- You were the only thing he was concerned about.
She smiles as the man in question,
heads up, and he goes,
what are you two talking about?
All right, I'm not gonna hold you up for long, Malthus.
I always talk to Baptiste, we are going to hold.
You know what, I don't want to bother anyone.
How soon do you think you're gonna be leaving?
- That depends.
- Well, in the letter that Baptiste sent me,
he said it would be about two weeks,
so I'm hoping Baptiste would recover in like a week or so.
- Oh, how fast is it?
- Okay, how about this?
You send this message to Baptiste,
because in the, no, I am a reckless guy.
I can't get this thing out of me.
Anyway, I want him to recover first,
and then we'll hold a proper banquet in the capital.
Just give him this message.
Also, you're here for two weeks.
I expect you stopping by from time to time.
All right.
Okay.
He heads out, cadence just waves goodbye to you.
Everyone is going down, and do we want to skip
to two weeks?
Is there anything you guys want to do?
Roma, you, yeah.
- I want to blow that fucking whistle.
- Oh, you.
- Those two horses come back.
- Okay, okay.
As soon as you blow the whistle,
you hear name in like the downs,
what was the billow deck essentially?
You never went to the billow deck, but they are there.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
All right.
So anything you guys want to do,
because I want to skip to where a fucking baptism can walk again,
and Bob can walk again.
Oh god.
And then you all want to do, or should I just skip?
- It's same evening that we work on the router,
we probably need to say something to baptize the problem.
- Okay. - Okay.
- First knock to see if he's up.
- Come on.
Come in.
Good.
I got some good news, but I'm going to tower.
(sighs)
The received is better from the reaction to the tower.
And it sets you to escape me.
- Your sister?
- Yes.
- Where?
- Hey, just that.
She escaped.
So, she is not, not under there.
Isn't somewhere anymore?
Around this time, you also hear like some,
someone like stumbling at the door, as,
I mean, you can go check it.
- Yeah.
- It's like making a fan listening in.
- Well, as you entered Baptiste's room
around the same time,
T-Gore woke up
and he saw you heading in,
so he tried to follow and maybe listen in.
But his legs are still like pretty hurt,
so he kind of stumbled on the door,
as I was trying to lean in.
So as you open the door,
you just see him like, following on the ground.
- T-Gore is it?
- Sorry, Captain, I didn't mean to.
Pride, but I just thought it might be something important.
- It is, but.
- Okay.
I don't have much more to go off of right now, so.
- Can I, can I ask who she is?
- Nice to meet you.
- And she was captured?
- First floor is we know.
- How does this person,
the king for all places, how does he know?
- No, what relation does he have?
I guess the questions that we should even look into
at some point.
- But did you happen to hear back from the damage at some point?
- That's what I was going to do.
- Might be best to also give me a round of 12.
- I heard.
But that's what we heard about before,
was probably heard in since it wasn't either for us.
- And there's another one.
- I'm good.
- But the more the better.
But T-Gore can I talk to you for a minute?
- Yes, he takes like a chair in the room
and this sits in front of you.
- I heard you, what you did.
- It's gone, I'm sorry, it happened.
I know I was reckless, but.
- Well, I kind of don't apologize to Laura.
He did good.
You did what you thought was right.
And I appreciate that.
I know I promised to protect you,
but in the state that I was, you ended up protecting us.
You ended up protecting me.
I made some arrangements.
He should be receiving something in the coming days.
And the riff also said he had a different kick to give you.
So I don't know what that is, but.
Just now from this point on,
you don't have to go as hard anymore.
You'll have more help.
And.
Thank you.
- Now Captain, I shouldn't be the one to thank you.
The one who saved me from the life that I was leading on that.
And if it wasn't for you, it would never have left.
And thank you for being patient with me.
- Very good kid.
- I kept it.
And he's gonna just kind of stumble and just leave the room.
Take this wheelchair.
- Okay.
Is this how the wheelchair just rolls himself out?
All right.
Now if you have anything to say to about T's before leaving.
- Everyone's the right to leave.
- I'll call.
- Who do you want to call first?
- Who do you want to call?
Ghostbusters.
You want to call me Mira?
- Okay.
- I'll give a Baptist to Dan and Mushy.
- Okay. You had the Dan and Mushy that you were carrying for a while.
- It was probably someone on the other side of his room.
- Yeah, yeah, probably.
So you grab it, you had it over to Baptist.
You close the door or you were in the same room or do you want to leave or do you want to?
- You want me to leave.
- Then I'll close the door.
So...
- Yeah, yeah. No one fucking listens in anymore.
Okay.
You call up the Dan and Mushy and it immediately picks up and goes, "That is the you."
- Oh, it's not the dude that...
- Yeah.
- You actually answer by your...
- Ah, don't even get me started on these.
These folks think that just because I'm here,
I'm supposed to be their protector or whatever.
Anyway,
Fenderus has already told me about your condition and I'm hoping that you're back at it.
- I'm still bad rust for the moment, but...
- Oh, come on.
I know you better than most. You should be leaping around the...
Mass by now. What happened?
Kind of been that bad.
You want me to stop and give you some...
Left and right?
Maybe that'll fix you right up.
- I lost my wings.
- Oh, shit.
- Um...
- I would have put my head up.
- What the fuck do I say to this?
- Just be yourself, Captain.
Yeah, yeah.
He did tell me something like that.
Well, Ed, you know...
Shit's whack.
Yo.
Oh, God.
- What did you...
was the bounty collected on...
Oh, no fucking Reese.
He...
Look.
We don't really care about the bounty, you know.
Black hand, the old man does not do things like that.
It was more of a personal grudge than anything.
He committed a crime that...
Well, no one should.
You know, what's worse than killing your subordinates?
It's killing your captain.
And Reese got what was coming to him, so...
- Well, it may not be much now, but...
The kingdom we're at right now has promised their support
if we ever need it.
- That's good, lad.
That's good.
We do need more...
- So...
- To help...
Almost all the contacts around the world...
miss...
Y'all, man's.
And...
Well, his disappearance has put them in...
quite...
a pickle.
All the...
islands...
that were...
using Black hand's flag up until now to them down,
because still...
Y'all man's gone.
And it's...
public news.
And if they don't take them down,
the Marines are gonna forcefully take it down.
Regardless, we don't have enough man force...
or the manpower to...
deal with this right now.
Right now, all we can do is...
do what the old man wanted us to do.
And once that's done,
our second priority will be finding what happened to him.
- Have you...
- Yes, go ahead.
- We...
are limited in power right now.
I know you wanted us to join up together.
- Yes.
- But...
you know, that joining might put us at even greater risk...
if we...
put us all in one spot to get wiped out.
We are stronger together, but...
awesome, or vulnerable.
- Yes.
I understand.
If you wanna...
take any of the other two missions that were already...
probably explained to you by...
Fandress, feel free to.
I don't think we need to...
get together at this point.
I'm trying to handle the situation,
but, you know, how bureaucracy is...
takes time.
- Not where I was...
leading to.
- Okay.
- Give me permission to...
form a new fleet.
- Form a new fleet under whose flag?
- It's still gonna be under black hand,
but I'd be...
a fleet commander of this fleet.
- Well, uh...
look, I have to...
if one thing that I learned from the old man
in the early days was...
this fleet business means nothing.
Just form your own crew.
Just form the people that you trust the most.
All of this fleet nonsense is because...
Renzo pushed him into it.
Wanted to show the old man's strength off.
It means nothing.
I have a fleet of five people.
And I think you are more than enough capable of handling your people.
You don't need to ask for my permission.
You just need to go ahead and achieve what you want.
Take the world by the strong kid.
That's what the old man wanted for you.
No, the Marines are gonna be on your ass...
in soon enough.
Have you made a decision on what mission you'd be heading to?
- Not yet.
- All right. Well, you still have time, so...
figure it out.
- I have enough advice that you provided.
- Okay.
- Well, I can't promise I'm gonna answer anymore,
but Trey is gonna be here, so I'll fund with that.
I actually, he's been asking me to hand the call over.
So here, she hand-stained, then we'll see to Trey.
Yo, be man!
Yeah, you handed...
You handed to?
- No, you handed me the hand-stained.
- Yo, be man!
How's it been, man?
It's been a while, hasn't it?
- I'm looking at a piece of like, what am I supposed to do?
- Hello?
Did you cut off?
Captain, did you hand over a phone with...
You don't need to cut it off?
Hello?
And after like a couple more, hello, he just puts it down.
- I'm sorry, this guy himself...
- Alright.
- Call Zinn as well.
- Okay, so this mission is our last time.
- Malfas, you wanna stay in or you wanna leave at this point?
- This one concerns me more than the other ones.
- Okay, why?
- I mean, she was the one that told me like,
"Alice, was there a capture somewhere?"
- These are informant...
- No, no, she told you that she heard that she saw someone in North Blue, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Does she know more?
- Yeah, okay, so you can take over when that happens.
- Baptiste, you wanna call?
Ghostbusters?
- Okay.
- You start to ring the radio mushy,
and essentially you don't ring, you just talk, right?
It's a radio.
So you just talk.
What do you wanna say?
- Then are you still...
Are you there?
- You hear nothing for a while.
And for a while it means like...
A few minutes go by.
10 minutes go by.
Are you still looking at each other waiting?
- Make a noise if you need help.
- Another like five minutes go by.
- She picked up, right?
- No, no.
It's not picking up, it's a radio, right?
So you just turn it on, you say something, and someone can respond or not.
- I first see Mayup and Captured.
- All right, so we wanna skip for the next day,
I do wanna talk about something.
- Where the... the mission she gave, the new options we got?
- Well, this just added a new option.
Do we know where she is?
- Yes, she told us where she was heading,
and where she was trying to infiltrate at least.
- I guess it's as she's still there.
- My name is...
- Any others?
- It's... we have the...
- No, no, no, trove and trove and trove.
- Yeah, there's a reason.
- Trove and me for the rescue, but also the initial mission that they were tasked with was finding Klein.
So that mean for you and what the...
- Just find him.
- It was her.
- Yeah, finding him as a reward for help, for Linus helping when he did.
Regardless, it'd be a reunion with the six bolts.
- Correct.
- So we just have to choose which path we wanna take.
- The question is, do we want to help where people are,
and if they don't graduate, someone else?
- I don't know.
If we go blinds in,
I'm gonna potentially learn more about your sister,
hoping trove and just helps our crew overall, helps the fleet overall.
And if we go find Klein,
you could potentially make an oberagement with the six bolts to get help.
- Well, I'm just...
I'm leaning more towards the trove and the war is in.
- I guess we have another few days to fill it out.
- I guess we do.
- Anything else?
- No.
- Before we skip on to the next day, can we...
- Mouse was went to the armory, right?
- Yes, yes.
- So the spell does not require material components,
but just for explaining it and for flavor, can we say that Mouse was bought some machine parts,
which Bob can later use to cast a fine speed or fine mouse spell?
- Sure.
- And it's a shopping cart.
- You know what?
- Yeah, sure.
Okay, Roma.
I saw that after.
Roma, do you want to do anything?
- No, I'm not.
- I'm not.
- Do you want to skip to the next day?
- No.
- Near midnight, one to two.
- Baptiste, can you give me a perception with advantage?
- Go, Baptiste.
- You should never roll the one D2.
- Oh, nice.
- I see, I see.
Baptiste, you hear a voice come over the Dendan Mushi.
Sorry, the radio mushy, not the Dendan Mushi, the radio mushy.
It's a voice that you remember, it's a voice that you despise.
It's the voice of the one person that knows your secret in the Navy.
- Oh, God.
- Well, well, well.
- Are you listening, little bird?
Are you gonna respond or no?
- I'm just gonna say his name, like, in very much.
- hatred, I see.
- You go, call his name, goes.
Captain Keller was to you.
Baptiste.
Now, see, I thought we were past these games,
but you sent one of your hundred links to infiltrate my...
Marie-base.
How?
What?
Smart.
Now, what was for you?
Now, that gives me two options.
One.
Blackmail you, which, you know, sounds very intriguing.
But, of course, you're gonna come and pretend to give up.
But I know you better than that.
I know that fire, that burns in the body of your people.
I know better than that.
Now, what I will tell you is that she is being taken to a hearing tomorrow in the North blue.
And once the hearing is done, she...
Well, it's more or less...
formality.
She is going to be executed.
And I would really like you to see her face when she does.
There's fair warning, because I know, I know you're kind.
You will try to get here somehow, some way.
And when you do, I will be here.
This time, I'm not gonna let you go like last time.
You better be prepared.
Little birdie.
I'm gonna get you.
You're gonna die like you was the cause of it.
Oh, I see someone's full of confidence.
Don't think that these past few weeks haven't changed me as well.
I'll see you on the other side then.
You cut off the radio.
And you hear like a crushing sound before it goes off.
I just broke our radio.
This was very hard to get.
All right, well...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go ahead.
It's like middle of the night.
I like to stumble out of bed.
And like make my way to the hallway.
No, you can get out onto the deck.
I would be able to master something, probably.
I'm going back to the north.
First off, shouldn't you still be a bed?
There's no more time for rest.
I'm going to go out to the back of the room.
As soon as we have everything set, really.
Our preparation.
Yes.
End.
All right.
Okay.
Drillman.
I'm going to take this place.
No, Dravos.
Dravos is.
Yeah.
I mean, you can talk to what's his name.
Fenderist as well.
It depends.
If you convince Fenderist, you might hand over Dravos.
I feel like I have a better chance of convincing.
Mirage let tell in the name of the moment.
Why?
Why would you think that?
I guess you'd know me from before.
Sure.
Maybe give her a call once you're all fixed up or when you want to leave.
How about we end it for today?
Good morning.
I have one more thing to ask you.
Okay.
Is your flag ready?
Your flag is done.
I think you're going to have to go back to the last one.
We're going to start with some more like the banquet.
First of all, like after a week, I'll just do a time skip for the week.
I'm going to maybe post some downtime actions depending after like the banquet.
We'll do another like week skip and I'll just ask like quickly what everyone is doing within that week.
If you want to train, you want to do something, just let me know.
In that meantime, Bob, you figure out how you want to flavor the changes so far.
And
Roll the puzzle devil fruit.
Oh, my intelligence bro.
It's not going to work anymore.
You want to give over the devil fruit or like the puzzle box.
You don't know if that's a devil fruit.
You want to hand over the puzzle box to the other people you can.
Otherwise you keep it.
I know I'm less more than before, but it's.
What's your score?
12.
I have 14.
Okay, hand it over Bob.
Your dumb is a brick.
I am my big.
The smartest guy comes up with a plan for saving them.
All right.
There we go.
How many rolls do I give?
How many rolls?
Is it like a week right on this point?
For the puzzle box.
I think it's like a week.
Just roll like 10 B 20s.
Why not?
It is a skill check intelligence straight intelligence.
We know that we're going to do the flavor after the session, but you know,
after we do the flavor, I'm going to have all this stuff from the savant or the
time when he's doing that check.
You know what?
Once you get the thing then we'll just say like the week that you were just
essentially just not you.
We're just going to skip that week.
No one says time to fucking solve the goddamn puzzle.
Okay.
One.
That's enough.
Two.
Three.
Fuck.
Four.
Now mine you fucking stupid.
It was a fish.
No, okay.
You try to figure the shit out and you eventually just like through sheer
randomness you click something and it seems to fit.
All right.
No.
That one.
All right.
You reset it.
Never mind.
Oh, my God.
Oh, fuck off.
Nine.
All right.
Nice.
And then.
All right.
Good job.
Just through sheer randomness you got one.
Okay.
Bob, can you just transfer it to a mouthless?
We also do Cades.
Things right now or no?
Let's just do it tomorrow.
Someone's waiting for me.
I want to.
I want to go for today.
Okay.
It's been six hours by the way.
That's crazy.
You know,
okay.
Okay.
Let me just drag it up into the mouth.
Is this cute to sheet?
Melphous figure.
Also,
what items?
I don't know.
Is it basically just all the dress?
Wait, what did you get?
Oh, oh.
Sure, sure.
Yeah, just just let me know when we have time.
We'll talk about it.
Just send me a message on discord.
Other than that, come up with a plan for them.
If you need like any context or like how it will happen or how your characters will know where it will happen.
It's stuff like that.
Just tell me in the DMs and you guys can just talk and you know,
your chat or whatever you want to figure out something.
I might post throughout the week like in the week.
Basically, I'll skip a week right now.
So that's three more days.
And I'll send like a little bit of like downtime actions from the other crew
in the chat because what they're doing is completely different and whatever.
I'll send that and
yeah.
Roma, you want to do your
Paladin stuff?
I mean, it's going to take one more day, I think, for Kola.
I'm working on the on the flag and the weapon as well.
It's crazy.
Do it over it.
All right.
I think that should do it.
For next time, I got to remember some shit, which is the banquet.
Then it's going to be another week.
So just decide what you want to train or have proficiency on if you want to train with other people.
None of the other people will have like any idea about hockey.
So you can't train on hockey, but you can try to train on different things.
Hockey, you will unlock at level eight.
So around that time, I'll put the tournament or like the training arc of the campaign.
So just be ready for that.
What?
One at a time, please.
Yeah, I was joking.
I'm not swimming with it.
Yeah, just drown.
Just kill yourself.
Whoever lives.
He's the only one who's going to live at this point.
Also, the thing that we're training, what kind of training?
You know, just D&D proficiency stuff.
Because for you, it's going to be like, you have to train with weapons.
You're not skilled with any weapons right now.
For the rest, if they want something, some proficiency is in something,
I'm going to say whatever applies for a week, just try to look into it.
And you can work on that.
I think I would probably be proficient in medicine at this point.
I think I would be proficient in medicine.
- It's about to be over there. - Hey.
- My last war-in growth. - Yeah.
- It was the A, it was still you, bro.
It was the B, you got to ask God the city.
Yeah.
But I still got up and still not your ass out.
I thought you were bad, bro. - God, my good brother.
I did the final thing. - And I help,
you didn't do it all by yourself.
- I threw up on my bedding.
- Nice.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah. - I'm passionate because
I missed the whole fight.
Did you record the session?
- I did, I did.
I'm gonna post everything, all of the wads
so far on Google Drive and I'll send the link again.
It's pinned, it should be pinned.
Yeah, let me see.
Yeah, it is pinned.
I'll just upload it.
And you can watch your individual fights.
I'll try to cut down the sections
or maybe edit them together.
So everyone's fight is different videos.
So you can maybe look at each other's fights.
Yeah, and fucking Matthew is gonna be real,
fuck me short.
- Mine was like 16 or 17 round.
- Yeah, yeah, his fight lasted like long.
- And that nice thing, but it was just me feeling, guys.
- Yeah, because the guys just did not,
we're not able to do anything, yeah?
Roman's fight was also pretty short.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- Yeah. - Well, the fuck we're on it away.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was literally the worst pairing.
- We're on it away.
- Yeah.
- Well, he had a sniper.
- Yeah, he had a fucking sniper on his ass.
(laughs)
Bob, you wouldn't have lasted a one round.
I'm gonna be so real with you.
The fucking crits that she had in Roman would,
it's crazy.
- Bro, Bob, when I tell you three crits in a row.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
Just not been right out of his fucking hybrid.
- Yeah. - It'd be cool.
- Yeah, yeah, it's crazy.
- Like, she hit one, so I said, fuck it.
I went hyper mode.
She hit another and then I was like, oh shit.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- And then the fucking knocked me back down.
I popped both my healing fucking shits
and she hit a third.
(laughs)
- I was on the brick and death dude.
Like, I was so pissed, but it was funny though.
Like, I wasn't pissed, I wasn't that like pissed,
but I was like, this is,
'cause I was not hitting anything.
- How do you finish her though?
- Oh, she made a big mistake.
(laughs)
- She shot me with the heart, the serum.
- Yeah. - I found it.
- I win.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if, yeah, yeah.
I don't know if you guys figured it out yet,
what the serum does.
But it's like a worse thing to give to a fucking runner.
Sorry, I'll make.
- It looks like it's like a, in the hands,
like a muscle on the top.
- It's not, yes, yes, it's like the rumble balls that Chopper has,
but it works on normal people as well.
- We broke it.
- I forgot what Camel I was.
- I don't think it matters.
- I mean, I said mammal after, okay.
It was at an old fucking table, okay.
I'm gonna update it maybe, but it's like,
it has adverse effects on normal people.
Just so you know.
As we've seen with the...
- She is a main, she's not a normal person.
- Yes, exactly.
And that's why what happened happened.
Do you think who the fuck was the one destroying the fucking
noble quarter?
It was fucking Roma, Roma fucking wrecked their shit, yeah.
- That's how the fuck it...
- Me getting shot with the fucking Hulk Serum,
I fucking went, was going too long,
so I was like extra months, like...
- Yeah, yeah.
- After it, bro, I literally, like, so she shot me with it.
I went fucking Super Hulk on the bench, ripped her apart,
like literally like straight down the fucking middle.
And then just started destroying the town.
- In today's whole session, everything they've been talking
about the whole scratchers and stuff that was used.
- Yes.
- And no one knows.
No one knows except for Baptiste and Malfa.
Roma doesn't even know.
(laughs)
- No, 'cause I was like,
"I'm trying to tell you guys..." - If you guys have watched, like, Dragon Ball Z, it was like, when Goku and like, the ape mortat first, he did it his grandpa. And he didn't even know that. It's kind of like that.
- No, 'cause I yelled at Roma, just I just yelled his name when he was doing it. So he came and attacked me, so I knocked him out.
- Yeah, literally, one hit.
(laughs)
- I'm destroying the town. I'm destroying the town. Like, Baptiste pops up.
Roma, what the fuck?
(laughs)
- I can't fucking run in full charge. He's asked two peacekeeping.
- Yeah.
- Did you like that again? Right now?
- No, like, this was one time.
- No, Sulaung? No, no, Sulaung. He can do inner beasts, but he still doesn't have control over Sulaung.
- Not yet. It's Sulaung has a full moon thing.
- Yeah, also, yeah. He can trigger it on full moon, but he has to make a wisdom save.
- Don't worry, Roma. I will do disadvantage on your wisdom save, so you can go Sulaung again.
(laughs)
- It was the fucking fucking shit. Like, I don't really just wrecked everything.
- I get it. I really gotta go, 'cause she's gonna fucking murder me.
- Roma, Roma, do you have... You don't marry, right?
- Yeah.
- All right. I just hope your wife does not fucking hate me, because I'm like six hours rose crazy.
- Both of them have to do that.
- I'm...
- What is it called?
- Yeah, I know. And she's texting me like fucking forever. I gotta leave. I gotta leave.
But you guys hang out. I'll be out.
- Yeah.
- But... - You tell us to not be mad at us.
- I can't promise that.
- Oh, but...
- But...
(sighs)
- Ah, hello.
- So, how's it going?
- It's going great.
- It's been six fucking hours. Oh my god.
All right. What you got?
What's happening? What's the...
Is there trouble in paradise?
- I'm not fucking lying.